e
okay let's open the public hearing on HB
383 welcome to housing I'm going to
start with the Pledge of Allegiance
rise States America to the rep which
stand One Nation God indivisible with
you and we will call the prime sponsor
representative
Aly I uh want to present the HB
383 it's about uh Condominiums and since
the housing committee I don't think has
anybody on it that has been having to
deal with this over and over marel were
you on
Commerce um I was on commer yest had
you're
right yes they're coming here which was
a
surprise a pleasant surprise in some
ways
since Commerce passes is about half of
our stuff but
on so I have two things here one of them
is a presentation to the housing
committee it's about uh condominiums in
our state and the wide variations in
them and the difficulty of uh
on providing law
for for groups that go from
over a thousand people in one seasonal
Campground I think it's about if I
remember correctly
4,000 uh to
duplexes and quad
plexes
where
uh we in I was uh I created the
condominium committee study committee in
200 and
10 uh and we had two Democrats and two
Republicans and we worked together and
we figured out everything we thought we
wanted to do and then the next term was
the O'Brien years so um the committee
went
uh went
on in a very different
direction and the term after that two of
the people from that and two new people
got together and uh have we'd been
working for quite a long time trying to
figure out how to provide
law uh for about governance that would
help
Condominiums uh to to uh govern
themselves there were that was my
original intent I run a uh 22 unit
Homeowner Association which I was put in
charge of 6 months after I arrived 30
years ago uh and got out of for five
years and got brought back because no
one else wanted to do it um but
um I realized that Condominiums and
homeowner associations which is what I
am is
are on
a
a sorry I've been in CTS for three weeks
uh it are small
governments some of them aren't so small
like Freedom New Hampshire which is uh
has this uh 4,000 something I think it
is uh unit summer well not just summer
but not not winter uh on essentially
Campground uh and it is a condominium
and it has it all of its documents in in
the uh Register of Deeds there but it is
a very different animal from four people
in one uh quadplex trying to work with
each other when one of them hates the
others or is hated by the others um or
they're fighting about whether they're
going to paint and and who gets to make
the
rules and uh there is everything in
between there are Luxury Condominiums
there are lowincome
Condominiums and
um the statute before we got together
and started working on it contained
almost nothing about how you
vote
on how you how you make rules
on what uh
acceptable forms of of structure
are and
on the group that I was usually in um
provided this structure
over the years but we also realized
eventually because every people didn't
really know we existed but every now and
then a condominium that was in trouble
would find out and people would would
come to our committee meetings and talk
with us about it and um there is
absolutely no
way to
uh
get if if a homeowners association or a
Condominium Association is run by a
manager who controls the board or is run
by a board which consists
of four or five people who appoint their
successors rather than have real
elections about it so that you get a
click that has had uh a one particular
idea of where the condominium should be
going you've got a lot of people outside
of them that uh disagree with this and
can't figure out what to do the only
thing they can do is at this point still
is to go to the uh Superior
Court and file a lawsuit that
takes at a minimum two years before you
get
heard and it costs about 20 it cost
about $220,000 10 years
ago uh to to do and during the time that
after you filed that lawsuit uh in a lot
of cases you're getting uh persecuted by
by the board you're getting fined for
for things nobody had ever heard of you
there was one extreme case of a
lowincome condominium that was within a
project uh that was going to be
developed as non low income and it they
started out with a lowincome one and it
was bought by a new developer and he
decided that he didn't want them there
and so there was an elevator there was a
woman who was
disabled and had real trouble walking
upstairs the elevator broke down all the
time time and there was was a person who
had red paint thrown at her door uh in
other places there would be uh the snow
plow would plow straight through your
lawn and winter uh and it can be quite
unpleasant
on and then there are cases where
um the after a long time of suffering
the people in the
condominium uh
turned uh decided that they were going
to take matters into their own hands
they
uh did a uh informal vote for for a uh
special
meeting and then they uh managed to get
the local police to stand by while while
they met with the board and the manager
who was the problem uh and they
undid uh they they uh legitimized the
special meeting and then they voted out
the board and the next week they created
a new board and they voted out the
manager and since then they've been in
great shape but it's
um it's it's a very complex thing
because a lot of the Condominiums have
different kinds of requirements for
voting and for other things a lot of
them make sense what do you do with a
4,000
member
uh spring fall
summer uh group that is really there to
play in order to get them
all or even a majority of them to a
meeting and then how do you run that
meeting that's totally different from
what everybody else faces so um that
that is
all and I apologize for saying it uh
apart from this
bill uh because um next year we're I'm
going to find some other people to help
me and we're going to bring in again the
bill that would allow a quasi Jud IAL uh
solution to this problem that allows
flexibility depending on the kinds of of
condominium that you've got
and this is based on the manufactured
housing board that existed until fairly
recently but was dormant for about 10
years before that uh they they set up uh
a was a Judiciary System which was
linked to the Judiciary System on and
they they would uh they had people from
all of the relevant uh
um parts of the problem on that were on
the board and they decided
cases on that were brought to them by
mostly
I think a couple of times by the owners
of manufactured housing Parks but uh
most of the time by members of those
parks and they they had a lawyer on
board with them and they would uh write
up the case afterwards legal in legal
terms and they would hand it over to the
Superior Court the Superior Courts now
have a wide range of cases about every
everything that could occur in a
manufactured housing Park and people
just have to go to the website find them
find the one that fits their situation
and go back to the other side of the
complaint and and say
see and and they that pretty well solves
the problem we really need something
like that for Condominiums and homeowner
associations the uh Municipal ass
Association for good reason never never
helps these groups but they are small
governments so uh that's uh that's
enough about that uh
that we've been struggling uh the same
idea of flexible law for the
for these
groups
uh we um
the condo com study committee was shut
down last year because it had been uh
there for over 10 years and we were we
were in fact still studying things but
they it looked like we were just trying
to help uh it on different groups as
they came in
and the problem was that that's the way
we were learning how to deal with them
in a way that we could put into law so
that they wouldn't have to keep
coming and
um we're going to I'm I'm going to go
to uh to with that other Bill about that
last
we HP 383 is an attempt to aform
condominium some of whose voting
practices are contrary to the existing
law on the
books uh including the 4,000
unit Campground
um
and uh last year we passed bill that
defined exactly what voting
proxies of different legal types are and
are not because there we were seeing
confusion that some boards were saying
okay we we can do we can do it this way
uh because there's nothing in the law
about that kind of
proxy
and and we um
man defined a bit passed a bill that
defined exactly on what different kinds
of voting proxies were and what what was
not considered to be um legal and
uh fair to the
community uh this year's Bill tries to
define the permanence in ability to
alter the original condominium
declaration which was made by the
developer and which most people think is
not
alterable but which in quite a few cases
does need some altering because the
developer was thinking more about
himself and his control than he was
about the community that would follow
him
um and also the byw laws which are made
partly by the developer and then added
to by successive boards and membership
votes and finally the rules which some
Condominiums have ex rules as well as
bylaws and some don't
um my Association doesn't
uh the rules are usually made by the
boards alone
but sometimes become the subject of
membership
rebellions it's required by law to
register the Declaration and the
accompanying plats with the registers of
deeds and usually the bylaws and amended
bylaws are also so registered a few
associations also register the rules
some associations have amended the
Declaration but their developer provided
a oh I talked about that already sorry I
thought it was time to start
standardizing but I now believe it needs
a group working on it to make it work
for everyone and we're not not there yet
uh Mr John Cummings sent you the
following suggestions for Amendment
which I mostly agree with but I had
expected I think maybe I've got someone
from his for
uh it says 400 it was
4,000 unit sees condominium in Freedom
to come and speak on the other side that
and there may be other associations that
have come uh if some of you would like
to work on the this issue including the
people behind I will work with you after
a retain decision otherwise this bill
dies and we figure out more of how to do
it next year and I wanted
to to uh add uh I made a mistake on the
first paragraph I wrote this last night
after doing everything else I had to do
uh and um I was thinking your ranking
member is actually on the municipal and
County
committee
so she is not among
you thank you very much I'm sorry if I
went on too long I'm
tired thank you representative Al me
questions for representative alme
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr
chair um representative Aly um uh in the
bill under um Roman numeral 3 the last
sentence there says the bylaws can be
changed by a simple majority of those
present at a properly noticed meeting um
do I understand correctly that you want
to see that changed to a majority of
unit owners and is that something that
would want to do after the bill is
retained or are you planning to put in
effect sorry I'm not planning to put an
amendment to that effect because I think
that the bill as it is hasn't had enough
people looking at it and what i' really
like to see is if there are enough
people here that are interested in the
condominium problem that uh they'd be
willing to work on a study of it during
during the fall that is retain it if not
then then uh we'll um I think what we're
going to be trying most next year is to
get that that
uh
on board on board for condominium
condominium work because uh the whole
the problem is is too big for our uh law
books new law book for all of it go
youe sorry you do agree that the B law
should only be changed by a majority of
I
um I am a little conflicted by it I we
have Pro a big problem of a lot of
Condominiums especially the ones that
start to fall apart are that uh most of
their members live in Massachusetts or
Florida or someplace like that uh and
they just um they get sent
on on proxies sometimes to uh to vote on
something and just told check the box
that is say you agree with all of it uh
by the board sometimes the board is very
good sometimes it isn't um
and uh there are also on a lot of people
my
Association uh we meet twice a year
there are only 22 units but only about
half of the units show up uh the others
are some of them are very elderly some
of them are are
working 20h hour
days uh and they they can come and
complain to any of of us anytime they
want to uh 22 units isn't too bad for
that if you got a 100 like
my my colleague down the road from me on
that gets
trickier and if you are in an you have
an apartment building with a th000 units
in
it such as uh one of the Reps a long
time ago was in on it can seriously fall
apart uh if if the board isn't being
renewed by different
people uh if the manager is telling them
what he thinks ought to happen uh in
that particular group it was uh a
problem that the original board which
continued to every time one of them had
to leave the others of them would decide
who was coming on next and their
objective was first and foremost to save
everybody money and they did that by by
not doing any maintenance for years and
years and
years and then people started to walk
away who had enough money that they
could walk away and the others
couldn't
so other questions representative
hegner thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative um so I understand you're
talking about these smaller um condo
complexes that are run by a board of
director s what about the larger ones
that hire these management companies
Evergreen condo management that come in
is Don't They isn't aren't they the ones
managing making all the decisions the
people that live there really don't have
any right to say I mean they hire this
company they make the
decisions um they handle the bylaws
getting get registered and all that
stuff so just trying to understand I
guess the difference between the board
of directors and then this management
company of the large there is always a
board of directors the board of
directors is supposed to direct the
manager on what you're describing
frequently does happen that the manager
directs the board and um that's what
happened in the first case that led uh
chair John Hunt to agree that maybe we
do have to do something because the that
was the one I described in which
everybody got together and forced a new
election with a police
present uh and then on got rid of the
manager and then came to his committee
and described what they'd been through
for 13 years they gave me a copy of a
letter they sent 12 years before to John
help and he he was the person in in
charge of the management company and not
the board of directors oh no John Lynch
was was was the governor of the state of
New Hampshire
okay so who wasn't helping them out the
board the management association that
was in charge of management
association was on playing favorites on
who would get
on get their Road their their section of
Road plowed and and things like that
they were on they were telling them that
certain things were in the law which
wasn't true on in the end when they got
rid of that manager uh she was a smaller
manager she only had two Condominiums
but there was a condominium uh halfway
across the state from them that heard
about it and threw her out two weeks
later uh but there are there are good
managers and there are managers to are
sticklers to everything and which can
sometimes cause problems too uh but
managers are supposed to and I was
trained by a manager the manager of e of
five eastmen uh
Condominiums uh when I first came back
home uh they
were uh she would hold annual meetings
and there would be discussion and
everybody would talk about about what
they liked and what they didn't like and
then they would would go away and the
board would act on it
properly
uh that on the kind that you're talking
about nobody gets to see who's making
any
decisions and those are the ones that we
really need and sometimes they're
small there was one
quadplex in which uh a woman bought
in uh she was pretty stubborn and she
was an accountant and uh she she bought
in there and discovered that the
um first developer of the of the
property uh lived there and had brought
in two friends and the friend and she
were paying less dues than the woman
that they
recruited she spent 2 years fighting it
and then I didn't hear from her again so
Massachusetts right other questions
representative
buolo thank you Mr chairman um thank you
uh representative uh Aly um so I'm I'm
trying to and thank you for telling us a
little bit about you know what's going
on with condos uh and condo associations
in New Hampshire but I'm trying to wrap
my head specifically around this bill HB
385 and the purpose and effect of this
bill so can you um please briefly
explain the effect of not recording the
rules are bylaws and what problem this
is solving
specifically yes well rules in general
in most places that we've heard of the
rules on if they're created or cre at by
the board
itself and people can come and complain
about them if they have
meanings um but they don't get
officially put in the I'm not sure why
the uh uh totem pole condominium in
Freedom um recorded all their roles as
well with the registry of
deeds which makes them hard to get rid
of again but um the the
bylaws sometimes do not end up in there
it depends on the condominium what they
decide to do what Their manager decides
to do um there is a condominium in uh
Hanover I live next to Handover uh which
uh was set up so that the people who
with the smaller units would pay the
same amount as the people with the
larger
units and there was a guy who contacted
me and said isn't there a law about this
and I said
no that that was my involvement
but so um it
does it every everything to do with
Condominiums and homeowner syst ations
is variable that's that's a difficulty
it's a challenge but
also um we need to do something about it
because there there's fairly decent
evidence not enough that there are about
a sixth of the housed population in this
state
and
the the the developers are now
concentrating on M making uh apartment
buildings for rent
because the the
way the cost of building and such has
changed has made it more profitable for
them to do that and they can do it more
quickly thank you representative Aaron
uh thank you representative uh alme
thank you Mr chair uh just following up
on representative B question is there a
difference in the way the bylaws are
enforced whether they are uh registered
with the register of deeds or not the
register of deeds does not follow up on
this I had one case that I took care of
during the summer that was referred to
me by by a
representative uh in that town and it
was a essentially a a ski condominium so
a lot of the people didn't live in it
and it was completely falling apart uh I
went to the register of deeds for her
and I found out that the the president
together with the treasurer with no
Knowledge from the group had had
uh uh
mortgaged essentially the
condominium to
uh to a local
bank uh and then two years later without
no idea that it been paid back but it
must have been paid back on they did the
same thing again but only the president
signed it because the treasure was now
no longer a member and was living in
South
Carolina uh that's that's the kind of
messes that things get into
but I don't want to take up too much
time because there yes I appreciate that
there are other people here to testify
are there other questions for
representative Aly representative Howen
um I'm just trying to follow up on
representative Aaron's question so would
my recourse be if you violated what you
thought were the rules just to go to
court
um that's the last recourse for all the
people that we've talked to because it
costs a lot of money
and because uh it takes a lot of time
and while it's taking that time you
n all right any other questions seean
thank you
representative um chair would like to
call I'm sorry just I'll leave that on
so thank you chair i' like to call on
Richard SWAT
[Music]
Alexander where would you like my
customer um you have copies for the
whole committee no um we'll take it up
you welcome thank you for coming well
good morning my name is Richard SWAT I
live at 26 Vineyard Drive and stratum
New Hampshire and thank you for the
opportunity to testify against HB
383 let me introduce myself to the
committee I'm a 17-year resident of The
Vineyards at stratum condominium it's an
age
55 year older and older condominium I
have extens extensive experience in
condominium governance and management
I've served six years on the board of
directors for years as a condominium
president and I serve on many committees
that assist the condominium board in
maintaining the infrastructure of the
condominium I'm also chairman of the
condominium Leadership Council I'm a
member of the New Hampshire legislative
action committee I have a 33-year career
in the financial services industry and
I'm a US Navy veteran The Vineyards
board the condominium Leadership Council
and the New Hampshire leader New
Hampshire legislative action committee
think this bill is unnecessary and is is
an example of changing the Condominium
Act because one Association may have a
governance problem due to the absence of
owner participation owner participation
in condominium associations is a major
problem today the owner's lack of
participation in cond condominium
governance is widespread but reducing
the threshold for amending condominium
declaration and bylaws will place too
much Authority in the hands of a small
group of unit
owners condominium documents as
described in RSA 356 B3 six are designed
to provide the rule of law stability to
Association governance condominium
declarations and bylaws are F filed at
the County Register of Deeds
representing covenants that run with the
land in
fact RSA 356
b35 contents of the bylaws it says there
shall be recorded simultaneously with a
declaration a set of bylaws providing
for the self government of the
condominium buying Association so bylaws
are filed with the
Declaration uh the vi The Vineyards
Condominium Association requirement for
changing the Declaration and bylaws is a
66 and 2/3 vote which is a typical
threshold for amending these two
documents lowering the voting
requirements to mend the condominium
documents reduces governing stability
and unintended consequences of
mischievous amendments the objective of
amending rule 356 b35 by inserting a new
section called formal rules of the
association seems to be to have the
rules become and I quote the force of
law by filing at the County registry of
deeds condominium associations take many
shapes forms and sizes I live in an age
55 older community there are
condominiums that have a majority of
Resident owners there are condominiums
that have renters in them and there are
condominiums that are seasonal
Condominiums the owners may come up for
a small period of time and they consider
it a summer home Condominiums are
elderly housing they're residential or
commercial they're single units they're
multi-story buildings there are
different common area amenities
clubhouses pools tennis pickleball
basketball courts open parking and
garage parking elevators and walk-ups
rules for pets and the list goes on the
nature of these types of rules invites
frequent change and having the rules run
with a land due to the regy of Deeds
filing is really not necessary
the requirement to keep the rules
current at the registry of deeds is an
unnecessary burden placed on the board
of directors which frankly today
are are overburdened as it is the rules
can be written so that the first offense
may result in a warning letter
subsequent offenses can occur fines
until the offense is remedy The Vineyard
board of directors and the condominium
Leadership Council oppos the passage of
HB
383 uh I will also say The Vineyards has
term limits so we don't have board of
directors going on and on forever and
ever term limits you can serve two terms
and then you have to not serve on the
board again thank you very much
respectfully submitted Richard
SWAT thank you Mr SWAT for your
testimony representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr sweat um when you refer ref to a 2/3
vote being desirable a desirable
requirement for changing the Declaration
or the bylaws were you um referring to a
2third vote of all the unit owners or a
2third vote of owners president at a
meeting thank you for that question the
answer is when we talk about an
amendment two-thirds Amendment for the
Declaration it does require a 2/3 vote
of the total unit owners when you're
talking about a change to the bylaws it
requires a two3 a 66 and 23 vote for the
units present at the meeting by either
proxy or
question I really don't know the answer
to that but if I had to take a guess
that condominium uh declaration is
probably of a higher priority than the
bylaws because the bylaws can uh be
different for each Condominium
Association because as I said before the
nature in form of Condominiums is not
all uniform there are many sizes and
shapes and styles of
Condominiums represent Aon thank you for
thank you Mr chair thank you for coming
in to testify if the uh documents are
not kept at the register of deeds where
is like the master copy of the bylaw is
kept and uh how does that work uh who
knows who has the latest
copy
well the documents the original
documents are filed with the in our case
the Rockingham registry of deeds now if
it's the annual meeting where we decide
to amend either declaration or the
bylaws it is the
responsibility of members of the board
to file those amendments at with the
registry of deeds to make sure that they
are a public record now if they if that
is not done I mean that would certainly
be uh a fault of negligence on whoever
is assigned to do that Duty on the board
other questions for Mr sweat seeing none
thank you very much thank you for your
time um The Honorable William infantine
up so formal Mr chairman thank you thank
you my name is Will
infantine I've served nine years uh nine
terms here in the legislature and I
think I've seen every condominium bill
that's come up including all the ones
that have come up every year
um uh some reason the speaker was angry
with me last term and decided that I was
going to be the chairman of the condo
committee so I got to learn even more
about some of the things going on and
Susan uh representative Alby and I did
work very well together get a few pieces
of uh legislation passed uh issues that
came up in front of our
committee you've heard a lot today about
uh asso condominium associations and
just to follow up on a few things I'd
like to refer to uh the bill itself
lines nine and
10 I guess I really don't care uh this
is kind of a uh something where if they
want to do it they can do it but as was
stated by Mr sweat uh the condominium uh
documents and the bylaws are registered
bylaws are very specific they deal with
um major parts of the association one
example of a bylaw change would be a
condominium that has basement that were
not intended for those basements to be
living area people make them living area
then there's water leaks and what have
you and a lot of insurance claims and
someone decides they should not be
living area anymore so we're going to
change that that's a significant bylaw
which you would usually have uh 2/3 or
3/4 of the uh members uh having to uh
owners have to agree to this whereas
rules are simple things you you can't
let your dog go to the bathroom over
there and you can't do this and you
can't have a certain flag on a certain
day and all the other things that come
up in certain rules those rules are
usually made by the condominium board
itself or if they're significant enough
uh is uh fines maybe for violating these
things they would come up in front of
the entire
board um so I think it would be
unnecessary every time there's a rule
change because there are rule changes
annually depending on what happens you
know no one knew anything about I
remember four or five years ago was
awnings what are we going to do about
awnings then it was satellite dishes and
all these other things that keep coming
up that you don't expect that you have
to change and make rules to having to
register these uh um makes it very
timely cost um you know costly and I'm
not sure it really does anything there
question was asked well where are these
things kept more often than not when you
buy a condominium uh the purchaser will
get a copy of these things before they
want to know the bylaws they want to
know the rules before they enter into
purchasing an association is common to
get these things the board of directors
and the management company has to
provide them to you so it's not a secret
as to what the these things are
um so it shouldn't be that that that
difficult um for people to find out what
these things
are my biggest issue is lines 13 through
18 where we're basically saying it's
whoever lines uh 16 and 18 the bylaws
can be changed by a simple majority of
those present at a proposed meeting this
was an issue was brought up in front of
Representative Aly and I last year at
this committee there is an association
where people just don't show up and they
can't get things done and that's that's
a problem with associations but that is
the nature of the beast when people
don't show up the board of directors
often time cut doesn't get is not able
to get things done and that is
unfortunate but it seems to work its way
out and I want to explain another issue
that occurred that came in front of our
committee last year a group of very
angry individuals in a condominium in
marac New Hampshire came in and they
were very angry because it looks like
the management company was
too close to the board and things
weren't being done and things weren't
they wouldn't when they ask for invoices
and things they were always being pushed
off um and then lo and behold my
daughter comes home one day and says hey
Dad my husband and I just bought a
condominium in this Association I'm like
oh that's just wonderful should don't
don't ever ask Dad or anything um well
she informed me a couple weeks ago that
the board most of the board got kicked
out and the management company is going
so it does seem to work its way out and
yes it is a frustration because do hear
things that are not good okay
people take that little sense of power
and they do some goofy things in these
associations U but we cannot make laws
for every single situation and this
group up in uh up in Freedom whatever
where there's so many people they don't
show up and it's a problem for them but
I'm not sure we can make a law that says
only the people that show up you have
five people show up in a 100 unit
Association and change some of these
laws
um I'm not sure we we need to change the
law just for for that one organization
and it is it is unfortunate uh one last
story I've served on four different
condominium boards over the years and we
have one Association where Airbnb was
becoming a problem our documents clearly
State you must rent for one week and
this is up in lonia and a lot of people
were renting for a bike weekend both
bike weekends you know how that could be
and um so
people would just thumb their nose up at
the rule so we wanted to implement a
fine a fine equal to like $300 a day
which would be kind of equal to the rent
to kind of say don't do this the laws
bylaws say this the rules say you can't
do this please don't do this we could
not get a majority of the unit owners to
vote for a fine all right that's
democracy I was on the board I wanted
the fines we didn't get what we want the
members said no
that's just the way these things work
it's a small little democracy and um we
don't always get what we want and and
couple years later you know they stopped
doing this so much and we didn't have a
problem so
they it would be nice to be able to
solve all these problems here in the
legislature but you always you can't
always do so I
I lines nine and 10 I would not agree to
the rules it's just too cumbersome in
paragraph 13 through 18 with all due
respect to my colleague who I got along
with very well and enjoyed working with
representative Aly I I can't support um
13 through lines 13 through 18 just
because it would be too detrimental and
then You' have a lot of people coming
back and say why did you allow if such a
small minority of people that showed up
to change the rules so respectfully I
would request that the bill be an
expedience to legislate thank you for
your testimony any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you and the last speaker I
okak hello
everybody Paul okak it's a nice Polish
boy from Western Pennsylvania oh that's
an N thank you there
you well how he won't this friend
Mr okay well really he's my cousin okay
but um I was from latro Pennsylvania
really but uh thank you all for being
here the the the issue is is we're
starting to swing things for a a vocal
minority will start to run the majority
and that's the concern
and I I don't know how else to put this
but I do understand where where boards
get entrenched and management companies
get entrenched and the landscaper gets
entrenched and whatnot but I got to tell
you I do this for a living I've done it
for 40 years and I'm the vice president
of Evergreen management so with that
being said we run about 300 associations
we have about 30 managers and uh we do a
pretty good job it's a profession of
perception we don't produce a widget so
you could have a room full of folks and
you've heard different opinions and
perceptions of how this business runs
it's never perfect we are run it the
flavor or if you would the direction of
the board and the board makes the
decisions we simp L follow through with
those many boards due to some
legislation are constantly asking for
advice on what to do how to do to
protect everybody at large and we try to
give that advice if not you've had some
condo attorneys speak before you before
that they're very entrenched in the
business and we we rely on them for the
legal legal assistance but I can tell
you I've lived in Condos for 40 years
I've been on board for four well not
about half of that I I say I am on about
300 boards because I'm out many many
nights at meetings and weekends and it's
a wonderful form of democracy the owners
elect the boards yes there are some
times when boards are empowering yes
there's some times when boards are weak
and they rely on management to to look
at things and help out but overall it's
a wonderful wonderful process and you
can see that and see how the moment is
building because back just about 40
years ago there were hardly any condos
associations in New Hampshire now
they're just going like crazy and people
are buying into them and they're not now
being segregated 55 and older and things
like that of which I qualify now but
it's a wonderful process and what's
great about the condo developments is
they're all different and you choose to
move into a community that suits your
lifestyle I would not move into an
association if it didn't suit my
lifestyle and thank goodness for choices
because if we didn't have the choice and
we do these types of things to make
everything Universal there will be no
more choices so I just really want you
to respect this of the vocal minority is
now going to be the majority very
dangerous thank you for your testimony
any
questions no thank you I will say I do
live in a condo association run by
Evergreen so oh thank you thank
you I I told my wife I'd be here till
5:00 I thought there would be I I don't
know what to do the rest of the day
we're the low drama committee on housing
okay all right thank you very much for
everybody is there anyone here to
testify on HB 383 seeing that I'm going
383 all right we're going to be in
minut
e
okay it is um 11:06 I want to open up
the public hearing on HB 410 and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Reed to introduce the
bill and pass us up a pink card when you
have a minute to fill that out welcome
I'm in the process of filling it out Mr
chair thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable
members so the Genesis of the bill
before you started with um the special
committee on housing last term the first
year in which we heard from multiple
expert
organizations um about how we got to our
current situation with zoning that we
maybe take for granted as just a given
and multiple organizations uh both uh
State and National organizations who are
who have expertise in this issue talked
a lot about how zoning came to be what
it is today essentially approximately a
100 years ago uh there was a Supreme
Court case
uh
uid that said that zoning was
essentially only legitimate in that it
was for the health safety and general
welfare of the community but not for
arbitrary Aesthetics that that would be
an illegitimate zoning issue um shortly
thereafter New Hampshire had a a Supreme
Court case on the same topic that echoed
some of the same findings that one was
called
sundine however around that time things
like um
redlining started to uh become more
popular and it seemed that zoning
ordinances followed suit in that they
were being geared to keep certain people
out of their community and other people
in and some of that was being done
through Aesthetics or through Aesthetics
that then added cost to being in that
community
so last year last year last term last
year I put in a bill that said any
zoning ordinances as that pertains to
residential uh property um needed to be
in keeping with those Supreme Court
cases the state and the federal Supreme
Court cases um and that if that they had
to prove that with the best scientific
current scientific understanding that
they had to prove that uh that that's
what those ordinances were based on
and then with working in working with
the former members of the special
committee on housing um across the aisle
as well as some of the other experts we
came up with this language which is not
where I want it but if you'll permit me
so essentially we're creating this
concept an extraordinary restriction on
residential
property yes towns can do these zoning
ordinances and what have you but to the
point that they are getting where they
are getting to the point that they are
preventing people from being able to
reasonably live even though they're not
hurting other people they're not
damaging health and safety of the
community that's when it becomes an
extraordinary restriction and if an
ordinance is an extraordinary
restriction then they need to prove that
is based on the best scientific
understanding of what is in the best
community the reason this is I think a
good approach and something that's very
complimentary with some of the other
bills that we've heard because it's
Broad in that it contains a lot of the
same issues manufactured housing lot
sizes um residential use and Commercial
zones however it's it is a safety net
underneath that because while those
bills each of those bills that this
committee has heard have been outright
prohibitions on those ordinances towns
cannot do this this is not saying that a
town can't do it it's saying that what
ever else we pass if we pass that you
can't and can and what have you at the
very least at a bare minimum if you're
passing it you have to show that it's
for the health and safety of the
community so I'll go through what we
came up with again uh Phil Sherman
helped with this language The Honorable
Josh Oella helped with this language um
it's not where I want it to be I would
ask hopefully that the committee would
support a subcommittee on this so that
we can get the language where we want it
to be um
but deadlines being what they were with
OS it is what it is right now so minimum
square footage on a house this is
something that would provide for tiny
homes we have a building code that says
that we have you have to have at least
200 square feet which is a 20 by1 um
dwelling which is a a nice efficiency um
but anything uh beyond that it would be
an extraordinary they can do it they
just have to show that there's a reason
the scientific reason for doing it lot
size requirements over 5 acres per unit
5 acre uh minimum neighborhood is a
rural neighborhood it is you can have
horses you can have uh hay fields on a 5
acre lot residential use on commercially
zoned Lots uh in commercially Zone Lots
I guess this would just be the use and
this is where we need to get to some
better language one of the places we
need to get to better language because
it's a little bit confusing how it's
worded
um in keeping with the other items on
the the list inhome business use and
residentially Zone Lots this is another
one that could use some help because
it's meant to specifically be for those
types of businesses that wouldn't be uh
noxious to anybody else not something
that would be noisy or you know burn
tires or whatever um but like a little
inhome cafe or let's say you're a
therapist and you want to have an inhome
office and have clients in your inhome
office or you're an archit te or Euro
whatever allowing for
that fees on variance applications or
building permits in excess of $100 for
owners who own no more than one property
and whose previous year household income
was less than 150% of the Town median
household income this is basically
saying if you're low to moderate income
and you need to do something you
shouldn't be find or feed have to pay an
extraordinary fee in order to get that
from the
town restriction on the amount of time a
property owner or someone authorized by
the owner May camp on a property so this
is the idea that you should be able to
camp on your own land you own the land
you should be able to camp on it you
should be able to allow other people to
camp on it this is not saying that
everyone should be able to camp on any
land you have to have legal access to it
it also that I don't know why OS uh put
it in a different uh paragraph but it's
also saying that the number of people
um shouldn't be restricted as long as
it's not below for per acre so this is
getting out of I would I would be open
for example to making that so if towns
could restrict it for being for like pay
so like you're allowed to let people
camp on your property but maybe not
start a camping site as a business
without the town's uh
authorization
so I'm also maybe interested in in
investigating with some other members of
the
committee where the appeals process
after the the the zba so those are some
of the ideas that I would like to uh
explore in terms of perfecting it but I
think that the intent here is really
good because it's very broad but it's
not a a direct prohibition it's getting
us back to that original purpose that
the Supreme Court set out yes you can
have zoning ordinances no it can't be
because you just want that community and
you want to keep certain types of people
or you want to have it look a certain
way it has to be for the health and
safety of the community um broad but not
too burdensome on towns so uh with that
I'm happy to take questions thank you
representative questions um
representative
baxton hi there hi so there's a lot in
this bill that I like cool uh and but my
I guess let me share with my concern and
there's some of it that I kind of like
well I don't know how that would work
but so my question to you
and and and quite honestly it covers a
lot of things that we see other bills on
which you you mentioned and I almost
think it would be better to have one
comprehensive Bill than a bunch of
little bills one thing here one thing
there which is what my concern is um in
my experience administering these things
or or dealing with these things as a as
a selectman and as a developer etc
etc we many times times find that we
have we pass RSA XYZ over here and then
we have rxa RSA zyx over here and
they're kind of on the same subject and
you wind up with a gridlock because
they're not worded exactly the same and
so instead of achieving the goal that
was the intent you actually wind up
locking things up so in the process of
working on this B I think this is in the
category of it certainly is a good
idea uh have you have you tried to tie
these back into the other rsas so that
there's not log Jam here thank you for
the question and you I agree with you
that I think it's important for us to
get to the whole entire point because we
have this peace meal we have all these
bills what about this what about that
when the whole point is the moving of
the goalpost way way way beyond what
Supreme Court said a 100 years ago
that's the problem health and safety and
general welfare as we might be able to
Define general welfare specifically in
this so getting back to that point with
one kind of simple this is the point of
zoning and you shouldn't exceed that is
really good um the reason I don't think
this will create a log Jam is because
this is setting a floor so for example
if we pass the manufacturing home Bill
the lot minimum Bill and uh the
commercial the residential use and
Commercial Zone Bill all three of those
bills the concepts are contained within
here but this is setting the floor so
while we're saying if you have that
ordinance you're going to have to prove
health and safety but if we've
prohibited that then you can't do you
can't even do it at all so but if that
would ever be repealed then we would
fall back on to well you still have to
prove health and safety so we're setting
a that is actually the job whenever we
have for example federalism with the
national government the federal
government and state governments the job
of the larger governmental entity is to
set the floor and then allow the more
detailed granular Administration on the
smaller level and in this case that's
municipality go
ahead so that's I I agree with all with
theoretical every theoretical thing you
said there I completely and totally
agree with so now we're in the weeds uh
the so we have one bill that says well
you can't have a lot size requirement
greater than 20 2 2,000 square
fet yeah 22 Yeah 22,000 square feet then
we have another then in this bill we're
talking about well you can't say you
can't say you can't require a lot size
greater than five acres you can you just
have to prove that it you need to do
that for health and safety right or
whatever uh or you might happen to have
one and it doesn't require that you
subdivide it either you're talking about
subdividing down and so that's fine my
question is so as an example as a if I'm
considering that we have people on
planning boards and Boards of adjustment
who are absolutely Volunteers in our
small towns and we've spent more time
talking about this here this morning
than they're going to spend in their
entire life but they're going to make a
decision on it is it going to be clear
to them that they don't have they
can't that they can't deny somebody the
right to have a five acre or have five
acre zoning or that they conver ly that
they can't deny the right of a
22,000 foot lot because it says
someplace else that they can require a
five acre I mean this is I'm just I've
been in so many of these battles over
the last 40 years right and they're not
always right but if we craft the bill in
such a way that anybody can get it on
the first reading that's my concern sure
and I appreciate that concern
a lot of times it requires referencing
anything anything we talk about requires
referencing multiple places in law
unfortunately um so this is meant to be
as I said a safety net if we then so
basically look it's not prohibiting
anything it's just saying you have to
prove it if it's this and then if we
then go back and say actually you're not
even allowed to do that at all that's a
really clear RSA in a different location
ad midly now if you want to help me with
language and somehow get to those other
sections of Law and maybe reference back
to this in each of those sections if we
pass the other bills that are covering
the same topic referencing back to this
just to make it super clear for anyone
who's reading those sections that this
this would also apply then that's fine
or whatever you might want to come up
with I think the point is I think the
intent for the majority of the the vast
majority of the committee is is the same
and I think that there's language here
to get to the heart of what's really
going on with the problem
here go ahead so and I have yeah that's
good um the other thing that I have a
concern about is that we
have
uh a couple of references to undefined
empirical data and so that sort of
concerns me uh is empirical data Google
is empirical data some statistic the
United States Department of Commerce
what it I I think that my concern is
that that's IL defined and I'm sure we
would all agree that we could find a
statistic to prove almost
anything uh so you know I think that's
an open door for confusion or danger or
simply not achieving the goals of the
bill so have you given any thought to so
my first that little loose nut down a
little bit sure my first um language
last year on this said best current
scientific understanding and then I
think there was some references to like
basically Federal organizations so
you're right that I think the point the
the minimum the lowest thing I can ask
for is for them to be aware them being
whoever is you know the towns to be
aware that this is you cannot exceed
health and safety if they then try to go
by disingenuous means to try to say yeah
self and safety that's a problem but at
least we've said look show your work
having said that I'm very happy to
strengthen this even further and if it
means defining what empirical evidence
is um the the process is the same though
right so they say here's the empirical
evidence and then first that goes to the
zba and then after that it may be
appealed further that's when I was
talking
about what's
that so I mean the the actual zoning
ordinance would be through the planning
board but when someone says actually
your ordinance is not then you go the
zba you go to the planning board
planning board would say no this doesn't
conform with our rules and then you go
over to the
zba sorry you'd go to the planning board
first even if you think the rule is
wrong and say here you're wrong I want
this permit based on X Y and Z and then
presumably they would turn you down and
then you would go to the zba and under
current law your next step is to go to
Superior Court where something like 92%
of
zba uh decisions are thrown out when you
get there but that's a long and
expensive well there's also the housing
appeals board and other other areas to
do and this is what I was saying is
maybe there's room to work on E either a
specific appeals process for this or or
something else um falling under a
different category but my point is is I
want to make sure that appeals process
is in intact so even if we didn't have
we could probably try to Define
empirical evidence as strongly as we
could try and there may be a town
somewhere that would try to
disingenuously say haha this is proof
right when we all know it's not so
that's why the appeals process
regardless of how we Define this the
appeals process is really
important representative Howland yeah I
kind of want to follow up on that as
well because in order for the ordinance
to have passed it's going to have to go
through the planning board and then the
legislative body is going to have to
pass it well you know the legislative
body is in most towns if you're sb2
that's your whole Community which is
going to be the people who were on the
planning board and on the zba and you're
going to have this IL defined thing of
empirical
evidence I don't I just don't see how
that's going to work very well I think
that in terms of you're saying the
system could be gamed well the people
who are passing the ordinance are
judging the ordinance so I I I just uh
how you're going to appeal it I I think
needs to be flushed out more well that's
exactly why I mean that wasn't actually
a question to me but I'll I'll treat it
as a question no no I'll treat it as a
question that's exactly why I said we
need to I would like to see this
Committee in addition to addressing um
tweaks in the language and the other
points to really hammer out a very solid
appeals process that's accessible to
people um and open by the way to to
anyone who wants to say hey you're this
town it I may not have a project that's
running against it but this town has
actually um passed a a um one of these
extraordinary restrictions and they
didn't provide the evidence or we think
the evidence is BS is that allow in
testimony um I did want to kind of
piggyback on that and and go to another
strength of this approach which is we've
spent considerable time and I understand
that we probably have amendments for all
of the bills on in question um the
manufactured housing the the uh lot
minimum and the
um residential use and Commercial zones
where we're really trying to get to
these details and we're like oh my gosh
these details are very burdens some
these details are you know how do we
Define like commercial versus industrial
and residential use versus res
residential building and you know we're
trying to really get in the weeds the
beauty of this is we are in this format
we are doing our correct job by setting
a floor and allowing the towns to get
into the weeds so all I have to do is
say um residential use of of a
commercial zone is an extraordinary
restriction then they can say okay but
this is a fine use of the extraordinary
restriction because it's a paint plant
and creates noxious fumes or this is a
fine uh reason to use the extraordinary
restriction they just have to show their
work that's literally all we're asking
basically that's all this is saying the
state is asking the towns look you can
do what you want but you have to show
that is in keeping with the point of
zoning you have to show your work and I
don't think that's too much of an ask
represent buo thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Reed um just to
Echo some of the comments uh earlier I I
think this is a this this bill and this
idea has an extraordinary amount of
Merit so I really like that this goes to
the root and it goes to um you know the
original um purpose of zoning ordinances
um I my question is in terms of you know
making the legisl local legislative B
show the work for the justification of
you know whatever the zoning restriction
is doesn't this in a way um make the
task of the other branches of government
easier because it you know really
focuses in um you know at the Town level
and um the actual zoning ordinances
focuses in on showing the work and the
reasoning behind but then it also leaves
behind a regardless of what the appeals
process is it leaves behind a written
record and a reasoning for whatever
judicial review process to go back and
take a look at to see and correct me if
I'm wrong but see that this is all
comporting with what the actual um legal
framework is which is health and safety
you're absolutely right in fact that's
why we have things like minority reports
and majority reports in our legislative
body in order to leave a record of our
legislative intent for future judicial
review so this is operating in that same
framework and you're also correct as I
said when you have the very um
intentional design it's it's it's
essentially a type of check and balance
federalism between the country and the
states but also the state versus
municipality you have a system where you
have two levels of government so that
helps to create a check on tyranny on
either level we've seen it you may maybe
it may be stretching the word but this
kind of what we perceive is a type of
tyranny on the municipal level and now
the state is stepping and say actually
you can't go all the way there you can
only do health and safety and so by
keeping that um balance in place what
we've seen is that when we're trying to
do this we're trying to get into the
Weeds on manufactured housing and is it
like any kind of nonstick built or is it
you know 3D printing or what do we we're
getting kind of far a field of our job
we're supposed to be setting that floor
the granular details are for the smaller
uh levels of government uh but when
we're trying to do these kind of
heavy-handed um prohibitions which I'm
not against and I've repeated voted for
we're we're struggling all of us to find
the expertise to go into that granular
level on these issues whereas this
leaves that open we're just saying look
we don't care what you do as long as you
don't do this and that is the correct
balance between the two levels of
government perfect any other questions
seeing none thank you representative
Dees well
welcome thank you for the record my name
is birie Dees I represent the nire
municipal assoc Association and we are
in opposition to House Bill 410 as it's
currently written um first thing I want
to state is planning board is not cited
once in this bill only legislative body
the legislative body is the voters so
our interpretation of this entire bill
is that the legislative body before it
adopts any kind of zoning ordinance or
amendments to their zoning um at town
meeting that someone from the
legislative body would have to provide
an undefined empirical evidence
published by nonpartisan Source there's
a lot of interesting quote nonpartisan
sources out there I bet many of you are
aware with them that you agree and
disagree with so just throwing that out
there um also the term grieved person in
the statute cited RSA 76 colon 5 would
be first that's not the right statute to
site because that specific section of
law only defines applicant and a butter
there's a separate statute and I can't
remember what the number is for the RSA
that um that does s site during the
appeals process a um an AG grieved
person um but
essentially our interpretation would be
anyone who believes the evidence and the
findings by someone who's a member of
the legislative body that they don't
agree with it could essentially stop
that zoning ordinance or Amendment from
being adopted um these planning
ordinance these planning and zoning
ordinances are debated or amended at
town meeting or in2 communities so I'm
not even sure when the public body would
get the opportunity to present to the
rest of the public body and the
governing bodies um this you know
undefined empirical evidence um again
legislative body is a term for the
voters in a community it's not the term
that we usually use in state St statutes
in the rsas for planning boards usually
you would site either the planning board
how it's defined in the rsas or you
might use a more open term like a local
land use board which is also defined in
the rsas um I pointed out that lines 8
through 12 anyone could prevent the
public body's will to amend the zoning
ordinances um appealing to the zoning
board a entire zoning ordinance to be
adopted is very unreasonable expectation
of the zoning board I mean their job job
isn't to interpret whether or not the
will of the voters is right or wrong
their job is to interpret zoning in a
community and whether or not to Grant
variances um or you know special special
use permits or other things of that
nature um so that's that would be a huge
change in expansion of zba's power um
this bill would also it would
essentially help municipalities from
adopting or amending any zoning
ordinance and I'll also mention even
those that would greatly incentivize
housing if one person decided I'm an AG
grieved it's not defined in state law
but I don't want any changes ever I'm
going to make my zba determine whether
or not the public body should be allowed
to make these changes um and I also want
to go on record and say that that zoning
is more than just health and safety
General Welfare is also a reason for
zoning um in the existing statute RSA um
674 col 17 that provides all the reasons
why municipalities may want to um to do
zoning and to have some of these
reasonable regulations that promote
smart and effective development in their
communities I also want to point out
that some of these um you know what are
defined as extraordinary restriction of
residential property would restrict uses
usages of existing property like for
example lot size requirements above 5
acres per unit municipalities need to
have larger lot sizes for agricultural
uses um that's to promote the general
welfare and the health and safety of
communities and to allow Farms to have
the space to farm without you know
impacting a Butters and a Butters having
to go and um basically you know be upset
with any farms in their area
um this also kind of establishes a
camping by right as long as it's not
more than four people municipalities
have an interest to kind of prevent
camping um on even on private property
due to health and safety um and again
you know I've mentioned in previous
testimony the the issues with
residential use and commercially zoned
Lots or allowing inhome businesses use
in residentially zoned Lots there's
several health and safety issues that I
mentioned on my long testimony
um I believe it was House Bill 631 that
would have allowed um residential use by
right in commercial districts so with
all of that um for this bill to even
work and be implemented in municipality
it needs a major overhaul um and just
the premise were also against because
you're basically tying the hands of
municipalities and their voters from
adopting again reasonable ordinances for
the health safety and general welfare of
their communities to promote smart
reasonable development um with that I
will take any questions
thank you mras can you give me an
example of when a non-empirical
evidence is unreasonable providing
non-empirical evidence is unreasonable
for
municipalities in regards to adopting a
zoning ordinance in regards to adopting
a zoning ordinance give me if you could
give me an example in which providing
empiric non-empirical evidence empirical
thing I think we requiring it is
unreasonable I think I think it is
because there are times where there are
certain aesthetic values that are
immeasurable um and there's I mean there
could be several other cases where it's
like you know five acres how how do you
exactly determine the acreage that's
good for a farm and preserving the
character of an agriculturally zoned
area you know there is some there there
is some subjective um things that voters
determine how they want their
communities to look I mean we can't deny
that but what we can say is that
ultimately it's best for the voters to
determine how they want their different
zones to be zoned um the kinds of
regulations that they have there and
usually most of the time they're going
to use some kind of evidence in their
findings especially if it's like a
variance or something the zba has to you
know there is that paper trail they say
these are our findings for are we're
going to Grant this variance X Y andz or
planning board when it adds
contingencies for development says you
know these are the reasons why we're
adding these contingencies and sometimes
there aesthetic things where it's like
you know this sign based on our sign
ordinance it doesn't fit um in our sign
ordinance is to preserve the historical
character of like a a uh historic
village District we had an issue that
happened with that in the town of
wolfboro with Hunters uh Shop and Save
being rebuilt the sign was much
different than what had historically
been there and would have impact the
historical value of the downtown
district and people visit wolfboro
because it's a beautiful downtown
district it helps our property values
see that people like to come to wolfboro
and want to live in wolfboro so you know
that's kind of an immeasurable thing
though I can't show you how my property
value or how neighboring property values
would be directly impacted but I know it
so thank you uh Mr chairman um so um you
did you did point out in your testimony
some of the uh you know languages uh
language in the bill that you know I
think rightly and other members of the
committee pointed out could use some
revision or could use some tweaks but
let's really go to like the spirit of
this legislation which is showing your
work I mean you know towns no one this
bill is not taking away a Town's ability
to you know pass a zoning ordinance it's
only requesting that you know if you're
going to do that to go ahead and show
your work so is the municipal
Association is it opposed to the idea of
towns having to explain the reasons why
they are passing zoning
ordinances I think it's extremely
unreasonable to expect the legislative
body to have to explain itself and
especially pinning it onto one or two
individuals that would actually do the
research for that I mean there's a
difference between how planning boards
and ZB operate whether or not they're
going to Grant a variance or how they do
you know site plan review and everything
and how they approve a development um
and how they you know post their F
because they do they add their
contingencies and their motion and the
requirements and they you know there's
debate and it's mentioned in the meeting
minutes what they discussed and you know
the planner keeps it with some of the
building documents and the zba has to
you know they show their findings as to
why they deny or approve a variance um
same case in in Wolf bro with Hunter IG
they had the grant a variance so then it
could have the parking lot in front of
the building rather than the building be
right up against Main Street and they
posted findings about how it would have
impacted um not just the ability of the
developer to rebuild what's a really
important grocery store in our town but
also the historic um uh look of our
downtown area our our kind of um our our
dense downtown area so you know these
things are being done but this bill is
written is essentially saying that
someone from the public body the voters
someone like myself you know or
yourselves when you go to your town
meeting would have to justify why the
entire public body is voting to adopt an
ordinance even if it's making it so it's
easier to develop in a community and
then one person who considers themselves
AG grieved could basically nullify that
and force the zba to determine whether
or not that was a legitimate zoning
ordinance that should have been
considered by the uh the public body
so I hope that answers your question I
mean we're kind of talking about two
different things and this bill is trying
to do one thing and using a completely
wrong terminology and its attempt to do
it which would ultimately undermine
local control and the
voters U thank you Mr chairman so uh
kind of my followup and one of the
reasons why I personally really like the
idea of the community showing its work
as you talked about you know well the
community you know deciding how it looks
and one of the things that I'm extremely
concerned about is a community not
deciding so much how the buildings in
the community look but deciding what the
people in the community look like you
know and as someone of French Canadian
descent historically in Northern New
England people you know who had last
name names like mine were excluded from
certain places in certain communities so
with the legislative body not having to
show its work can you suggest something
that you know we could you know some
kind of tweak or something to make sure
that these zoning ordinances are not
being passed for reasons which would
implicate fair housing violations which
would have a disproportionate impact on
certain protected classes and categories
of
people I'm not aware of any uh zoning or
planning ordinances that are currently
in violation of fair housing um I think
the zoning districts and the regulations
they have for them are they're the same
for everyone who wants to move into that
zoning District or wants to develop in
that zoning District it's a fair and
equal playing field um and ultimately
the voters are the ones who determine
what the uh what the zoning ordinances
will be in a community and how district
is to be developed and um that's
probably the best place uh for the
decision to be made ultimately is with a
planning board working with a you know a
town planner or circuit Rider to develop
um smart reasonable zoning ordinances
and to present them to the voters to
justify them and to look for the voters
approval or at times disapproval well
for we had one year where we voted down
every single planning and zoning
ordinance that's how we felt that year
so you know um some years they all pass
Pretty you know it's dependent by town
too so ultimately um you know and also
this assumption that there isn't a paper
trail that planning boards and zoning
boards um have they do have that and
that's to legally protect themselves as
they're trying to implement the zoning
ordinances and to interpret them based
on the will of the voters and um so they
do keep that paper trail and as
representative Faxton mentioned um it's
for when there's appeals right when
there's an appeals either to the zba um
or appeals to the uh to the um to the
superior court or to the housing board
um so you know again this is a pretty
complicated issue and to try to address
it in one bill and make the public body
have to justify its votes is very
difficult it's very unwieldy I'm not
sure how any town could possibly
implement this properly without someone
basically finding this loophole and
using it to stop any zoning ordinances
amended representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify this morning um I
have two questions
um and the first one is that you
mentioned a concern that the bill refers
to the legislative body of the
municipality but doesn't mention the
planning board in reference to providing
um empirical evidence but couldn't the
legislative body um have the planning
board or someone from the planning board
provide the empirical evidence and if
the planning board is a governing body
it's not a legislative body they're two
distinctly different things so by having
the governing body present the empirical
evidence which is undefined um it
wouldn't be the the it wouldn't be the
legislative body now I guess you could
say theoretically they could collect all
this empirical evidence and then provide
it to a someone who's a member of the
legislative body to provide it to
everyone else but we're not sure where a
form would exist because these planning
you know these Planning and Zoning
amendments aren't especially in SP2
towns they're not debated at the town
meeting so I'm not sure where there
would be a a proper venue to to even
discuss whether or not these empirical
findings are legitimate and you know
ultimately then you have this AG grieved
party um that isn't mentioned I mean
they cite RSA 676 col 5 Roman 1 um but
that terminology agree party isn't used
anywhere in that statute the entire 676
colon 5
um it's just I'm I'm not sure how you
you could make this bill work as it's
currently written it's just it's a very
unworkable piece of legislation and we
see the intent and we still disagree
with the intent but just for the
committee to understand I we wouldn't
know how to tell a municipality to do
this because it's just not possible
follow up on the first question yes
follow um thank you
um you um
mentioned that there would be no way to
get this information out in sb2 town but
couldn't it be mailed out to the
voters if I guess theoretically you
could create a mailing requirement and
the taxpayers could pay for you know why
zoning amendments are being adopted to
be mailed out but then again the ballot
in sb2 towns there's a statutory
requirement that they explain what the
zoning or the planning amendment is
doing right as an explanation and it has
to be understood by kind of in layman's
terms so that kind of is already done if
someone goes and reviews the ballot and
becomes a knowledgeable voter and
understands what exactly the zoning
amendments are that are being presented
to them that they ultimately will be
voting on so couldn't the evidence be
part of that explanation on the
ballot I know I can speak from personal
experience as someone who's a member of
the legislative body in wolfboro is that
every year our planning board has an
information session it's coming up I
want to say this Wednesday or Thursday
and they explain why they're making each
zoning Amendment change they record it
and they put it on the town's website um
that's something you know different
communities have different capacity to
do those types of things um but I
wouldn't recommend putting the
explanation of quote undefined empirical
evidence or sorry undefined quote
empirical evidence um on the ballot the
ballots would end up being like you know
be hundreds of pages
long my second question um is about
about the um 5 acre um provision and
that is that the bill um would um uh say
that that the uh municipality has to
provide evidence if it's going to
require anything larger than 5 acres and
you mentioned that 5 Acres isn't big
enough um for a farm but the fact that
they can't that the town can't require a
lot to be larger than 5 acres does that
prevent a farmer from buying a lot or
buying several lots and putting them
Acres that's a good question I'd have to
do some more research on that but um I'm
not entirely certain there are many
people who are trying to buy a bunch of
lots in a residential area to create a
farming um you know a farming into to
start a farm and um I'm not sure what
the rules I would probably guess my best
assumption that um there's probably
rules in local municipalities for how
you can combine Lots um and they're
probably governed what those rules are
you know some level by state RSA but um
I can't speak exactly to that I wasn't
anticipating that question this morning
AR aren't we talking about rural farming
areas and really about one person buying
a farm from someone else or a family
buying a farm from another family um and
that farm could be as big as necessary
the fact that the town can't require it
to be bigger than 5 Acres how does that
prevent the farmer from having a farm
that's bigger than 5 Acres so that would
be that wouldn't be a change of use and
it would probably be already existing in
an agriculturally zoned area where it's
permitted if there was already a farm
there um the concern would be if someone
was in an area that um someone was in an
area that permitted farming in the zone
and all of a sudden the you know the
community um can't require lot sizes
larger than 5 Acres but it's
advantageous to require 10 acre lot
sizes for the farm because based on the
farming practices that are done in that
Community that's this amount of area
necessary to have a farming Enterprise
where it doesn't impact the abuts in a
negative way where the abuts are making
complaints and complaining about you
know an example might be in a lot of
farms they have a lot of runoff and a
lot of that runoff has high amounts of
um different um I mean really it can
smell and the runoff can pollute
neighbors um well water compute you know
groundwater on neighboring Lots so
having larger lot sizes for farming is
important for protecting Community
Health and um and the the abutters
health and the uh property values of the
abutters I mean there's been examples
where people have tried to farm on lot
sizes that are significantly smaller
than what's probably required for the
type of farming they're doing and where
people go to the town and complain about
you know different different health
issues and different smells that they're
that are coming from the farm that's
impacting their lives and their private
property thank you thank you um
representative Dumont and then
Daxton just one quick question to your
point can you explain to me why a
municipality would need to tell its
residents that and why the residents
wouldn't be able to figure that out on
their
own you you'd be amazed how often people
buy buy land or buy um homes sight
unseen and haven't actually done their
due diligence to see one if the lot can
even be developed whether or not it's on
a class six Road or a class four or five
Road I mean there's several reasons why
and why why you know people might not do
their due diligence to understand the
lot that they're buying and what uses
are permitted there and how it's allowed
to be developed but um the
municipalities their concern is that
they're putting regulations in different
zones for the communities to protect
health safety and the general welfare
and to um to basically promote um smart
and reasonable development go ahead so
followup so what you're saying is that
the municipality knows better than the
property
owner no that's not necessarily what I'm
saying what I'm saying is the
municipality is trying its best to
balance the needs of property owners and
the general Community to promote health
safety and Welfare and to adopt
ordinances so then the development
doesn't impact other property owners
negatively it's trying to balance the
rights of property owners that is that
is the goal and to promote health and
safety and the general welfare of the
entire Community um so it isn't one
property owner that's doing development
at the expense of everyone else
especially esecially those who are
already existing you know peacefully on
their lots that are zoned for the
current usage that they're using it
for representative
taxon so I share as I said earlier I I
share your
concerns uh I don't hate the bill uh
the I think it's a basket full of
interesting or good
ideas um I disagree with you about the 5
Aker aspect I see I go back to what
representative Gibbs said I don't I
don't see how the fact that I require I
can't have bigger than a 5 acre doesn't
mean I can couldn't have a 50 acre and I
think it's important for the the commit
the the committee to understand one of
the things are are are we have
176 towns in this state something a
whole bunch a whole lot and everybody's
got a little bit different zoning and a
little bit different take on it so and
in my towns the Two Towns I represent we
still have traditional town meeting y uh
and if this came if there was no fix on
this in this past which I think it needs
some fixes my your your point is you
don't know how the town would pres would
handle this well in an SP2 town and in a
town meeting format you have a budget a
joint budget uh and town warrant hearing
it's a town warrant which includes the
zoning changes month or so before the
town meeting or the vote and you would
that's where you would hear as we did in
my town last week the zoning the
proposed zoning changes if anybody cares
which oftentimes they
don't so Mike I I think that's a simple
thing and maybe it needs to be spelled
out more clearly in the bill um but I
think it's important to understand that
in my town There's No Zone that either
explicitly allows farming disallows
farming you want to have a farm knock
yourself out uh and to the further point
just because somehow we got on the
subject of farming under the current New
Hampshire law if you own a piece of land
that is less than 10 acres but you
generate uh the majority of your income
from agricultural means you can have a
quarter acre lot in uh current use
rather than in the typical the rule is
normally 10 acres or more so there's a
lot of variations that I think we would
be need to be conscious of in what we do
here because we don't want to we don't
want to mess things up I do have
concerns as I said earlier I do have
concerns about the bill I think some of
the ideas are really good I think some
of them are less so but and I do your
point I think is really the point I was
making earlier in terms of the current
system of local governments that we have
in New Hampshire which there's about
50 you we need need to make sure that we
structure this in a way that the
implementation doesn't con make it more
complicated or confusing and make it
clear who's supposed to do what uh the
your the point you make of one
individual tying up all the zoning in
town forever while I would hate to think
that that's true you could at least time
up for half a dozen years in court
proving that that getting proved that
you were wrong if you were really
motivated so um I was that a question
that was a what all right I think we're
getting I think we're like this is going
on longer than I expected it to um so
are there any other questions or can we
move on Mr DET thank you very much
back just turn the mic on
please chair Alexander Vice chair Cole
members of the committee it's an honor
to be back before you today again my
name is Samuel Hooper I'm legislative
council with the institute for justice a
nonprofit civil liberties law firm uh
that works nationally to work on issues
of economic Liberty and property rights
we have a zoning Justice project
specifically that um fights to try and
end the kind of exclusionary zoning that
we see across the country that can limit
property rights and a contribut to the
housing crisis um J is supportive of
this bill um we think that there's some
word smithing to be done potentially but
we're very um admiring of the intent
behind this bill because it introduces
the rigorous standard a more rigorous
standard of review for um for zoning
ordinances that impose extraordinary
restrictions on property rights and by
requiring municipalities to actually
show their working to justify some of
the restrictions that they impose on
property rights with empirical evidence
um and show a necessity for those
regulations based on health and safety
this bill kind of mirrors what in the in
the Jud process um we we have the
concept of strict scrutiny whereby if
there is a um um an infringement or a
restriction on a fundamental right um
the government has to show a compelling
government interest in having that
restriction in the first place and also
show that that restriction is narrowly
tailored to the least restrictive means
of achieving what the government's goal
is um um you know at the moment strict
scrutiny tends to be um reserved for um
you know core fundamental rights so you
look at issues to do with um uh race for
example um it currently doesn't extend
to property rights and in the world of
property right a much more lenient um
standard of review exists rational basis
review where pretty much anything the
government says um the court has to
defer to and take face value and we see
this just RIT large with the kind of
restrictive zoning or ordinances we see
around the country um that can be quite
Preposterous not at all rooted in health
and safety in any way um but just have
to be waved through by the court because
they're not allowed to um you know
exercise any additional kind of review
um we like this bill because it kind of
approaches the issue from a high level
top- down perspective so we think it's
great to have more granular bills
looking at minimum lot size looking at
manufactured homes residential and
Commercial all of that's good but
sometimes it's also good to go back to
first principes like we're big on that
at the institute for justice um we've
seen a similar Bill actually um
currently um make quite a lot of
progress in Montana where they're famous
for their Montana housing miror they've
done a lot of work um on bills
unfortunately this bill I think it was
Senate Bill 146 um having passed the
housing committee it then failed on the
senate floor and a very close vote um
there was quite a lot of coordinated
opposition from some of the municipal
leagues but it did a similar thing it
tried to sck that concept of strict
scrutiny and just tell towns and cities
look show your work if you want to
restrict property rights then just show
how this is actually tied to something
that's not just um a backhanded way to
stop certain people certain types of
housing from existing Community um it's
not an onerous requirement at all and in
fact it could potentially save City's
work because by doing this work of
justifying the zoning ordinance upfront
once um and getting you know um judicial
confirmation that that's um a valid
ordinance you then save yourself having
to fight the same appeal a hundred times
when different agreed Property Owners
then come up and try to dispute it so we
think it's better more efficient use of
government resources as well to do that
work up front um so again um if um I I
commend this bill to the committee I
think it could be very good I think um
it would be worth more exploration of
some of the specific um uh specific
Clauses in the bill to make sure that
they do achieve their desired effects um
but we we very much like how this
interacts with the other bills actually
um we think that establishing that floor
of basic property rights is really good
um and then um the more detailed bills
to go into minimum lot size and other
things can serve as supplementary to
that so again thank you very much for my
testimony I'm very happy to take any
questions the committee May are there
questions representative
buolo thank you very much uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for your testimony
um given Institute for justice um and my
familiarity with it in terms of it does
um uh quite a bit of uh litigation and
things like that regarding like you said
economic Liberty and property rights um
I would presume that Institute for
justice would be quite familiar with
different uh appeals processes and
things like that would it be possible to
maybe submit um you know you mentioned
word smithing or tweaking some of the uh
things with this bill I think one of the
concerns is the appeal process would
would Institute for justice be willing
to maybe submit any kind of proposed
tweaks or ways um that the appeals
process for this particular bill could
play out absolutely um in the course of
our litigation we've had a lot of
experience in different states and
municipalities and they all vary
slightly but I would be more than happy
to base on our research um to provide
some supplementary testimony to the
committee to suggest some potential
improvements in that area that'd be
great thank you other question questions
seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman is there anyone else here
that's willing that's um planning on
testifying on HB 410 seeing none I'm
going to close the public hearing at
11:58 um so we will be in recess until 1
o00 I want to invite my colleagues down
to the State House cafeteria there's
free lunch there by the bipartisan
housing caucus that representative Paige
and I work on um free lunch and maybe
you know conversation about housing so
we'll keep the the party rolling if
you'd like to be there so we're in
o'clock
e
man
okay the time is 101 1 p.m. I'm going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
457 and I'll recognize um a co-sponsor
um to introduce the bill Representative
welcome thank you Mr chairman my name is
Sam farington I represent Rochester Ward
4 and I'm here today to introduce House
Bill
457 some might call it the Frat House
bill before we talk about the bill it's
important to know the background behind
the bill and why we're here today right
now across the state of New Hampshire at
least seven municipalities have certain
zoning ordinances that limit the number
of unrelated people living together in a
single family home college towns like
Durham especially Durham have adopted a
three unrelated rule meaning no more
than three unrelated people may live in
the same single family
house it doesn't you know you don't have
to be a genius to understand that this
restricts the supply of housing but also
equally important it infringes on the
property rights and the economic freedom
of an individual right now in Durham it
reduces the supply of housing and this
is
particularly you know visible as a UNH
student myself right now there's a very
tight housing market rental rates are on
average $33,000 a month if you're
looking for an apartment to rent you got
to search for at least a year in advance
and it's just blatant discrimination by
the town of Durham against UNH college
kids against young professionals that
might not have the budget to live by
themselves so they need to pull together
and they need to combine efforts into
renting maybe a single family house or a
duplex whatever it may be but for
example in Durham right now if you have
a say a five bedroom house the realtor
cannot lease that house
to five unrelated college students but
it can lease that house to say a family
of eight I mean it just doesn't make
sense from an economic perspective we
all know that we're in a housing
shortage right now and a IST might call
it a market failure meaning that the
market does not efficiently allocate the
the supply of housing meaning there's a
shortage right now and people are
demanding more housing than is on the
market the
solution well sometimes with market
failures people seem to think that it's
government
regulation but in this case it's
actually deregulation because government
created this problem in the first place
and we see this all across the housing
market not just housing for college
students government gets involved they
set certain
regulations and it's harder to build
it's harder to lease and it drives up
the cost of housing so HP 457 here today
has two main
Provisions first it prohibits zoning
ordinances based off a familial
status and then secondly it prohibited
zoning ordinances that restrict
occupants per bedroom to less Le than
two less than two
people that's the bill and unfortunately
I got to get back to committee so I
won't be taking any questions thank you
representative
Fairington okay so with that I probably
have about 15 pink cards we're going to
try to keep it around three minutes if
you could um on your testimony but um I
will call on next uh representative
uh good afternoon thank you very much
for taking my testimony I'm Wayne Burton
um I am a 50-year resident of Durham uh
and I am a 11-year member of the
Durhamtown
Council um I am representing the
legislature on the public higher
education study
committee uh my background I have
uh Ed from uh
Vanderbilt and I've been a college
President but mostly I'm very proud to
be a a Durham resident we believe that
when students are sent to us I believe
that there's somebody else's kids being
sent to our care and it's up to us to
keep them safe and have them learn
something about being a responsible
citizen in our
town I I have to mention that uh last
night the Durham Town Council after long
research changed its zoning so it's no
longer less than three and Todd celik
who's the Town Administrator in Durham
uh is better in position to talk about
that I also want to tell you that dur
I've been on the straford regional
Planning Commission for 13 years and um
and certainly aware of the
housing challenge so much so in Durham
we have now passed a Workforce housing
overlay district and we have three of
them now where our zoning will be
suspended one of them is a 100 Acre Farm
that I'm personally working on and um
and I strongly believe as the others in
Durham that having unrestricted zoning
is is not unrestricted but zoning that
fits our situation is is the best way to
go um and I I would hope that you listen
to the testimony from the town today uh
safety is the most important thing for
us learning about citizenship is second
most uh the student
affairs I want to say that the seventh
item on our agenda every meeting is a
report from the UNH student Senate
external Affairs chair or their
designate the chair of their designate
is a wonderful young woman who who who
met it with us last night the student
Senate at UNH is not taken a position on
this legislation the student Senate they
are discussing it but they understand
because we have a dialogue with them all
the time about housing issues in town
and I would urge you to listen to the
testimony taught is here the fire chief
is here and others from Durham on why
this is important but I would also what
I'm what I'd like to do if it's okay
with you Mr chairman last night when we
met the Town Council passed a resolution
on House Bill
457 we love House Bill
457 if it has an amendment that uh
representative Howland is offering and
so I will pass this out and I'd be happy
to answer any questions that any of you
may may have well representative right
on three minutes thank you very much um
are there questions for representative
Burton
yes I don't have any for you thank you
very much much okay so I'm going to call
on um Todd
seelig just the natural order of things
on
up so my name is Todd selig and I'm the
administrator for the town of Durham I'm
accompanied here today by Audrey Klein
our code officer David Emanuel our fire
chief and brandan O salivan our Fire
Marshall we're here to testify against
HP4 57 as currently presented to answer
any questions you may have and to speak
in favor of an amendment that rep alen
plans to
introduce Durham is host to UNH and we
have a significant presence of college
students who impact the socioeconomic
characteristics of our small town the
census indicates that Durham has about
15,400 residents that figure includes
UNH students who live off- campus in
Durham and by comparison UNH has an
enrollment of around 11,400
undergraduates so there's a significant
influence and impact managing the
commercial use of off-campus student
housing is a fundamental and overarching
issue in our town as it is in college
towns such as Plymouth Kean hover New
London and ring New
Hampshire the construction of around
2400 new privately owned off-campus
apartment beds in Durham since around
2011 has created opportunities for
incoming students to move into safe
state-of-the-art professionally managed
and walkable housing from surrounding
communities in straford and Rockingham
counties that includes communities such
as New Market Dover Portsmouth
summersworth Rochester Lee and Madbury
to name a few freeing up hundreds of
regional apartments for traditional
Workforce and producing simple ample
off-campus housing for our college
student
population what's different about
Durham's rental housing market which is
true of most college towns is local
rents are derived on a per bed basis
this Market Factor creates an incentive
for landlords and Property Owners to
rent to college students rather than
conventional renters seeking Workforce
housing because their gross monthly rent
can be twice as high driving up property
prices and rents to the point that most
conventional renters and families simply
cannot compete financially against the
student housing rental market and its
investors Workforce housing units behave
fundamentally different from non-family
commercial congregate living catering to
undergraduate college students
particularly with per bed student
rentals with individual leases promoting
A Boarding House type of atmosphere over
many years Durham has thoughtfully
adopted a host of regulations to address
the impact of college student housing
including our noise ordinance an open
container ordinance our trash ordinance
our disorderly house ordinance parking
ordinances Fire and Life safety
regulations and more but Cornerstone of
our ability to manage density and use
within non-family Commercial College
student housing units has been through
local
zoning I want to State unequivocally
that Durham is doing its part to address
New Hampshire's housing challenges as
ref Burton noted two months ago we
adopted what we called an attainable
housing ordinance overlay and now look
forward to the construction of as many
as 200 additional rental beds on a large
parcel of land along Route 4 and Durham
this would be a appropriately located
and managed to attract the much needed
local Workforce that we're striving
toward last evening after months of
review the council as rep and councelor
four specifically identified commercial
zoning districts all walkable and
proximate to the UNH core campus and all
service by Wildcat Transit bus service
this local change limits the number of
occum in a dwelling unit based upon the
state fire code we understand that rep
Allen plans to introduce an amendment to
the committee that would ensure
municipalities may not adopt occupancy
ordinances that are more restrictive
than Allowed by the state fire code if
as a committ you ultimately believe that
A Change Is warranted to RSA 67416 we
feel that rep howland's amendment is an
appropriate solution it would eliminate
potential inconsistencies between local
zoning and the state fire code and it
would make sense thank you thank you for
your testimony questions for Mr
selig representative miles um I was just
wondering why it doesn't include grad
students or why does it exclude grad
um uh we typically graduate students
live a very different lifestyle and have
substantially different needs than
undergraduates they don't tend to live
in large uh congregate group settings uh
they behave uh fundamentally differently
more like uh a family would and so it
simply is typically not an issue uh we
have a lot of adus that graduate
students live in uh there are apartments
in town that cater to graduate students
but it's a it's a niche market yeah M Mr
C could you elaborate on that because I
guess I'm wondering when you say
conventional housing what does that mean
and why is that different from student
housing isn't it just isn't housing just
somewhere where somebody lives and I
guess to follow up with that why is four
students living in it in a unit not a
problem but five are like is there a
magic number there I guess I'm trying to
understand what we've found found over
many years is that the more
undergraduate college students who live
together as a unit that lends itself to
uh challenges that don't coincide with a
traditional family neighborhood um you
end up with lots of cars you end up with
trash you end up with parties those are
things that we regulate against but you
also end up with large groups of young
people walking to that house at say 2:
in the morning and along the way they're
not breaking any laws but along the way
they're waking up all the families along
the street heading to the event and
heading back from the event and so we've
just found that limiting the number of
um undergraduate students makes good
sense and we've tried to uh discern what
an appropriate uh break is for a
traditional residential use versus a
commercial use just as you do with a
hotel for example there are specific
characteristics of a hotel versus a
boarding house versus perhaps duplexes
Tri triplexes versus a single family
resident or department and there are uh
breaks that we create to differentiate
which zones in terms of use are
appropriate and our determination
consistent with a fire code is that five
is a good number the what the fire code
says as I understand it is uh up to four
uh you treat that as a single family
type residence when you get to five
individuals who are not related to one
another in any way that then triggers
the uh fire code requirements such as a
sprinkler code Etc so you could have for
example a family plus that would be
considered one and then you could have
three more that gets you to four and
that would be acceptable in a
traditional residential use under our
new ordinance but if you had five
then you end up with a a specific
commercial use that we're calling
student rental at this time okay and and
just just to ask one more question do
you believe that the way your ordinance
as adopted would discriminate against
five people with a disability that are
unrelated and living together do you
think that opens up the town of Durham
up to potential lawsuits by redefining a
certain Zone based on unrelated people
we we don't we've uh very carefully
identified the zones where we've allowed
the five or more and these are zones
that are serviced by a network of uh um
uh uh sidewalks and uh bus service
they're all walkable to the core campus
they're walkable to our downtown so they
make good sense for this use and it's a
use that's consistent with other uses in
this Zone uh multifam multi-unit uh uh
high-rises that are three or four
stories with commercial on the fourth
floor housing above we have uh
fraternity houses in one of the zone and
it would be allowed in that zone uh so
uh the zones are all walkable to the
court campus okay thank you represent
paig thank you Mr chair I'm just seeking
clarification the um the greater than
four unrelated people that unrelated
language am I correct in understanding
that's in the fire code um the fire code
defines a it's and again we've got
Brendon Orin our fire inspector if you'd
like he could give you a very succinct
answer would that be
helpful could you could you feel a pink
card for us but please come up and yeah
first fill it up first no you can speak
and then just fill it out and hand it up
to us thank you my name is BR and I'm
fire marshal for the town of Durham uh
the currently adopted here why don't you
why don't you pull up a chair and speak
sure sure okay sorry squeezing in
snuggle on up all right no
photos you're on video my
name my name we are my name is Brendan
oin I'm the fire marshal for the town of
Durham I'm also a part-time unh I've
been in the community for over 30 years
uh everything that was said I agree with
the breakdown of the
2021 Life Safety Code which is adopted
by law specifies a single family home
can have up to three Outsiders if they
go to four it becomes a lodging and
rooming house it's a completely
different type of occupancy and they can
go up to
16 if they exceed 16 becomes a dormatory
questions for the fire inspector
specifically representative Gibbs thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr fire
inspector um but isn't the difference
between uh a uh house occupied by four
unrelated people and five unrelated
people is requirement for sprinklers
isn't that the main difference and is
there any other important
difference yes once you have five UNR
ated you're lodging and rooming if it's
a new lodging and rooming you're
required to have a sprinkler system a
fire alarm system separation between the
first and second floor and each of the
automatically other questions represent
howand um this is just clarification of
the new ordinance so uh in the new
ordinance that the town of Durham pass
which uh
identifies um student rental there as
long as they have uh that fire
suppression in place they can there's no
limitation on the occupancy other than
what state fire code says right that is
correct and then anywhere else in Durham
from what we just passed there is no
nothing that uh says you can do greater
than what fire code is occupancy is set
by fire code right that's also correct
yes represent miles thank you Mr
chairman
uh another clarifying question so a
family of eight could live in one of
these
buildings and they could have three
Outsiders so 9 10 11 so they could have
11 people in
one building but if they're just three
or four unrelated people they're maxed
at four now they could have up to three
the family could have up to three if
they go to four it's the equivalent of
five unrelated the family be in one
group and then there's four others that
are unrelated follow up following that
not really so so in one situation if
there's a family and some Outsiders they
can be up to 11 11-ish the family can be
any size and they can have up to three
people in a in a this dwelling correct
but if they're for students
unrelated that's that plus plus the
family it's a lot no forget about a
family just separate
separating separating the family plus
three
Outsiders separate
question students only so it's 11 or 12
versus 3 four in the same
building individually yes you could have
the family plus three Outsiders and you
would not be a lodging and rooming you
could have four individuals with no uh
relation with each other still be a
single family home not a lodging rooming
if you add one more Outsider to either
one of those two categories you now have
the five but in one situation you can
have up to 11 or 12 but in another
situation you can only have four yes in
the same size building the same number
of bedrooms yes the code the code is
specific on including his three
Outsiders so Mr inspector if the
students got married you could have up
to six
right if the students if they got
married to each other yep no I'm just
I'm trying to like understand how
ridiculous is it if they if they get
married to each other you can have six
students living in a place under the
fire code yes okay thank you
representative Gibbs and representative
howand thank you um for practical
purposes why should the requirements be
different for five people who constitute
family and five people who are unrelated
you have five people regardless why
should the requirements be
different absolutely the code makes
reference that it's their understanding
and I say there the committee that
established it that there is more of a
reason for a family to look out for each
other opposed to five separate leases
where you don't even know when those
people are coming and going but suppose
you don't have five separate leases
suppose you have five people who get
together as friends and I did this when
I was in graduate school um who get
together as friends and decide to rent a
house um with one lease one person signs
a lease the others pay the rent to that
person so it's a group of people who
watch out for each other why should the
requirements be different we actually
did this with eight people big big house
um why should the requirement be
different for those eight people than
for an eight person
family the language the code separates
them as related or not related the annex
of the code goes into that detail but
the annex is not
enforceable and that has never been
clarified to my knowledge but why I what
does the annex say the annex says that
the intention of the unrelated is
separate leases it does not go into the
detail of whether or not there's one one
lease which would then make them
concerned about each other because
there's one person answering for that
lease and then the sub leases to the
other four and I'd I'd love to get a
clarification on that if that passes the
definition of having not necessarily
relationships but an interest in each
other's wellbeing well let me go just
aurther can can I go just a little you
can have a followup yes one more okay
um back in the day when I was doing this
um we didn't have per occupant leases
you had one lease per house or one lease
per apartment usually one person signed
it sometimes a group of people would all
sign it but in any case it was one lease
and a group of people were responsible
for it and why should that be a problem
that still isn't clear to me I'm not
saying that's a problem and I'm not
saying that that shouldn't be clarified
but it would need to be clarified in
order to be selectively enforced that
way
okay representative
Howland this is just to clarify her
question because and I I understand I've
worked with uh the Fire Marshall and
that on this and it it does confuse
people so to her question she was saying
like um if you have three unrelated and
a family are in there and it becomes
identified as a lodging house or
actually what was it when we get to five
and it qualifies as a lodging house you
have to put a sprinkler in but the
occupancy is is goes up to the ma
maximum that's allowed by the fire code
for the a lodging house so it's actually
that house regardless of whether you had
students or any unrelated is 15 right or
16 you go up to 16 16 so you can put 16
people in that the question I guess
phrasing this the question fire code
says that a lodging house as long as you
meet the sprinkler and other suppression
systems can hold up to 16 people is that
okay other questions for the fire
inspector thank you and if you could I
don't know your name so I'll F this out
sure thank you thank you um any other
questions for Mr selig representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify um I want to
follow up on um representative
Alexander's question about five disabled
people um suppose five disabled people
um wanted to live together outside of
your Zone um uh because they need to
support each other and possibly be
supported by personal care assistance um
would you would you try to prevent
that
um within the uh zones where the student
rental is
allowed if they are enrolled full-time
college students the ordinance would
apply if they are not enrolled full-time
College students the ordinance would not
apply so it would depend on a number of
different
circumstances uh followup go
ahead why would why would that make a
difference um well we've we've just we
found and this goes to the issue of
family plus three living together if a
family is present within the rental that
family unit will materially change
change the characteristics of that
housing upon the neighborhood and the
use will behave much as a traditional uh
residential use would versus a
commercial use that has a very different
impact on the surroundings and so we've
identified the four zones where we feel
the impact would be very appropriate and
consistent with the nature of those
zones and outside of that you would be
allowed to have four so if there are
five uh disabled individuals they would
and they were full-time college students
they could live within the four zones
we've identified together if they are uh
living outside of that zone there'd be a
limitation on the number of people and
if they were full-time students there'd
be a limitation on the number you'd be
allowed four not five and those young
people would have to decide which four
would sign the leases and the other ele
that's changed I think since you may
have been in school and we renting with
your uh colleagues is that today in
college communities the rentals are done
on a per bed basis so a landlord is
typically not saying here I'm going to
rent this single family house to you
representative Gibbs and you can have as
many people live there as as you'd like
um instead the landlord is saying I'm
going to rent to every specific person
who's going in there and the more people
I can put in there the more Revenue I'll
receive but why followup uh followup
thank you um but why would you put that
against the testimony that I can
personally uh give you of eight people
living together completely unrelated to
each other but as friends um why would
you put that
against my
testimony well we've found those over
many years that um if you have eight
people living together who are full-time
college students living off campus their
behavior will by and large not be
conducive to the traditional family
neighborhood and in an effort to
preserve those neighborhoods and
preserve housing stock available in
those neighborhoods for the workforce
housing we'd like to create um this uh
ordinance change made sense to the
Durham Community but this would not be
true if they weren't
students um if they are not students
then the characteristic of those
individuals the lifestyle is uh
profoundly different from if they are
students
so when you say traditional family I
guess I'm wondering like do you mean
specifically like a husband and a wife
and like two kids is that what dur wants
like two kids on single family lots
where like they have little
neighborhoods stuff like that like I
guess like what do you mean by
traditional family because there's a lot
of different families and they look a
lot different and why is Durham trying
to zone out certain parts certain
families from certain areas of town so
in the 1980s when the no more than three
unrelated ordinance was put into effect
the vision people had of families I
think was exactly what you outlined but
we recognize as a community over time
that has profoundly changed and so when
we speak of tradition family
neighborhoods I guess you could strike
the word family and say traditional
Workforce housing neighborhoods
traditional neighborhoods with people
who take an interest in one another who
care for their property care for their
neighbors who know one another who
operate on a lifestyle that's fairly
consistent you know getting up in the
morning to go to work coming back having
supper going to bed at a certain hour
now sure there may be individuals who
are working a third shift who come home
in the middle of the night or early in
the morning but those folks are going to
by and large be very respectful of their
neighbors where what we found is that
college students live on a very
different schedule they are going to bed
very late they are sleeping late and
unfortunately there's just an inherent
conflict in Lifestyles between non-
full-time college student undergraduates
and everybody you know and the the
students and so we're just trying to
find a way to preserve our neighborhoods
so that they remain enjoyable places to
live wherever people are whether they're
a single person a married person a
traditional 1950s family or a family as
we know it today we don't care we
welcome everybody but we're trying to
very thoughtfully figure out where this
student lifestyle fits in and where it
doesn't and that's the Nexus of our uh
regulation representative
Reed thank thank you Mr chair thank you
for your testimony and for taking my
question and I think I might have a few
follow-ups um so I apologize for not
hearing the beginning of your testimony
I was um testifying on a different Bill
across the hall um but when I hear you
talk about the lifestyle differences and
how these people are different from that
people I my concern is that that's
really veiled not even very veiled um
what I would call discrimination
realizing that student is not a legally
protected class um but discrimination
against students and so my question is
and this came up last year what is
stopping the town from enforcing
ordinances regarding noise enforcing
ordinances regarding garbage and
relatedly are you aware that the data
that we heard on the same bill last year
um showed that actually most of the
noise problems and the domestic violence
disputes and all of that happened with
families wives and husbands fighting and
children being noisy those little
nuclear families that you see to want to
protect from the students and not as
much from the actual students who do
have to go to class at 8:00 in the
morning
actually so we we have um I I listed it
but we have a a noise ordinance a trash
ordinance a disorderly house ordinance
various Life Safety codes in place and
we um consistently enforce those based
upon complaints and our
observations um and it's important to do
that to ensure that everybody can
coexist
uh in a uh Happy environment that's what
we're after um what we observe over time
is at least in Durham New Hampshire and
probably in Kean and Plymouth as well
that the vast majority of noise
complaints trash complaints Etc are
focused on student rentals because
they're very active they're active late
at night they host large Gatherings if
you have three undergraduates living
together it's typically not three it's
the three plus there are three uh
significant others who are over they do
host Gatherings at off hours and it
creates a nuisance for non the non-
student population and so when you have
a community of more or less 6,500
full-time residents like you and me who
are living there with their families
going to work every day and you have a
student population including graduate
students of around 13,000 14,000 people
people there's a profound influence on
the neighborhoods and UNH does not have
enough oncampus housing to house all
their students um there are not enough
um professionally managed properties in
town to house all the students so
there's a certain number of the student
body that moves out into the uh
neighborhoods and we welcome them in the
neighborhoods as long as they behave
well but we find that the greater the
number the more likely it is that they
be challenges and that's what was the
Nexus behind the 1980s era no more than
three unrelated is um we also experience
a real challenge where the student
rental dollar because it's on a per bed
basis is much much stronger than any
other classification and so we lose what
we're trying to create and so
desperately want which is Workforce
housing to the off-campus undergraduate
population so what we've tried to do
with the new ordinance the council
approved last night after months of
review a lot of discussion was to try to
align our ordinance with the fire code
so we've moved away from the definition
of family and regulating based upon
family which by the way Duram went to
court on twice and the New Hampshire
Supreme Court ruled twice that it was
not discrimination to discriminate
around the issue of family that there
was in fact a a recognized and bonafide
State interest in preserving the welfare
of families and you couldn't
discriminate against families but
students as you correctly point out are
not a protected class and uh they are a
a a a a profound uh part of our
community that we work hard to welcome
to integrate in a successful way but
large numbers of them in certain
neighborhoods just don't mix well with
the non-student population it's not that
people don't try but I guess what I
would say to any of you is come to
Durham and I'll set you up for 2 or
three years in a house in a traditional
neighborhood uh where we have a lot of
student rentals and talk with me after
that and you'll experience firsthand
what it's like and I don't mean to be
crude saying that but that's what Durham
residents come to their officials the
Town Council our code office our fire
department to express profound concern
over it and so we're we're working
really hard to find a way to manage this
really difficult
situation followup thank you um so just
to clarify your last Point um I've lived
in the neighboring town of New Market
where a lot of students do live for 15
years I also got my Master's Degree at
UNH where I drove for Wildcat transit
for three years and I drove the late
shift so I'm very familiar with the
partyer students and um happy to visit
Durham again for that purpose but I I
feel like I do have some direct
knowledge I appreciate that Durham has
made their or more legal and my pointing
out that it was illegally if it had been
enforced illegally enforced in the past
was not around the idea of a protected
class for students or familial status it
was around the idea that we have a law
saying specifically for adus you cannot
make any Distinction on familial status
for the adus and if the some of the
housing was Adu related then that was
not legally enforced um so to my
question I keep hearing you say things
like they they and they are a nuisance
and they are doing this Behavior it's
very um cringe inducing they don't mix
well they aren't fitting in with the
community and I it it kind of sends up
some red flags for me so um I my
question is because I'm really trying to
get it what are you actually trying to
divide here if it's not this kind of you
know this this stigma around students
are you aware that students who have to
study and have to go to class in the
morning and take tests and do papers
also would find loud music and
disruptive behavior a nuisance and
conversely are you also aware that the
nuclear families living in the preferred
regions of your town um also stay up
late in fact the workforce housing you
keep mentioning a lot of those people
are hourly workers that work late jobs
they are not normal 9to fs and they also
might enjoy an adult beverage and they
also might enjoy music so are you aware
that the these two groups of people are
not as distinct and actually share a lot
behaviors so
um the ordinance that Durham sunsetted
last evening was not illegal it was
legal and uh sustained that way on
multiple occasions by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court and we believe what we've
put into place is also legal and
represent present an improvement moving
forward um I think that last year you
brought up during the proceedings an
important point which is the cost of
enforcement and you had made a statement
that it wouldn't be an issue for Durham
because UNH has its own police force and
they would police off campus and that's
not accurate so to the extent that there
are Cs and there are caus by the student
housing Pres
those our increased calls to our Police
Department our code enforcement our fire
department to address these issues the
reality is that undergraduate student
renters are different in that they are
young they're energetic they're learning
how to live on their own for the first
time uh they're exploring boundaries um
and they tend to live very different uh
lifestyles in terms of the hours that
they keep so on a Thursday night a
Friday night a Saturday night Durham
starts to pick up uh activity around you
know 10:00 and it continues until 2 am
in some areas and we're just trying to
put that activity where it belongs with
similar types of activity and we're
trying to keep that activity to a
minimum in areas where we where
typically non students live and that
type of activity fundamentally impacts
quality of life and so
uh again I appreciate you live in New
Market I think one of the things you've
experienced over the last 10 years is
because of the 22400 beds we've created
in Durham we've pulled that student uh
element that student body group out of
New Market largely out of Portsmith out
of do how do I know that because in the
early 2000s when many of the UN students
were living in those communities the
city managers in those communities would
call me and they would say Todd how do
you manage student housing because we're
having all sorts of problems and we're
not successful in dealing with it and
what Durham has done is pulled those
young people back into town so that they
don't have to have cars uh it's much
more efficient they can walk to class
and we really pride ourselves in
ensuring safe housing as well and that's
one of the objectives of our code office
and our fire department these are young
people who are renting for the first
time who are very inexperienced and we
want to make sure as well they're not
taken advantage of by landlords who are
sometimes interested in taking advantage
of young people so we have an interest
there too in terms of the Health and
Welfare and safety but again I'm not
trying to Sugar cat to step around and
I'm trying I'm sorry if I'm raising red
flags for you but uh undergraduate
college students behave profoundly
differently when living off campus in
larger numbers and we're simply trying
to very thoughtfully manage that and to
put the undergraduate students where
there are Services where there are
similar types of uses and in a manner
that doesn't create disruptions with the
the majority of the rest of the
community go ahead yeah go ahead um
thank you and one last question so
should this bill pass is there anything
in this bill that would somehow run uh
against the new version of the ordinance
and I do appreciate that uh the Supreme
Court found it was legal in regards to
familial status or I'm sorry
discrimination on students I was being
very specific about adus and that
literally being against the current Adu
law but you have a new ordinance now I
like it a lot better it's a lot cleaner
um doesn't have as much problem and I'm
hard on it we've worked really hard on
it no it's I think it's great I'm I I
think it's a lot better my question is
if this bill passed does that give a
problem for your new ordinance
it does yes this bill would um strike
down uh vast parts of the new ordinance
and that would in essence leave durum so
that there would be no restriction in
terms of where undergraduate students
could
live representative
Hicks thank you Mr chairman so to seek
clarification where I think you are
saying my undergraduate student at
UNH I somewhat know what she does in the
weekends
and I would not permit that at my house
where she has grown up because it' be
disruptive on weekends and week nights
is that what you're saying yes thank you
it is and if if there is a non-student
adult living in the property going to
work living their lives whether they
have family or not they take a very
different interest in long-term view of
that property and quality of life of
themselves and their neighbors then do
the individuals in a student rental now
are there some student rentals that
don't cause any issues there are there
are many but there are many that do
cause profound issues for neighborhoods
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um have you
ever heard comments and these comments
are something that I can testify to both
from personal experience and from
handling housing cases at the New
Hampshire Human Rights Commission have
you ever heard comments that the worst
noise problems can be caused not by
students or children or teenagers but by
unhappy marriages that can result in
people screaming at each other at 2 and
3:00 in the morning every night and
putting their fists through walls on a
regular basis have you ever heard that
um we uh so yes and we have um
individuals unfortunately who are in
that situation and the police do respond
and they're very difficult police calls
but that does not constitute the vast
vast overwhelming majority of our police
calls
ours uh very largely surround the
student undergraduate experience and
parties that are taking
place so it's very different
represent thank you thank you for taking
my question um does UNH have enough dorm
dorm housing for all the
freshmen for freshmen and now UNH also
requires all sophomores to live on
campus okay that was my followup
question which has which um has created
a softening in the rental market in
Durham so our professional landlords who
operate the um off-campus multi-units
the high-rise type uh buildings
typically they're close to 100%
occupancy for the last 2 years they're
somewhere between now 80 and 90% they're
really feeling a concern um in addition
there are fewer students who are
enrolled at the University it's down
about a thousand from several years ago
so they're feeling the pinch there as
well so
um uh so then would it be a true
statement to say that the most
inexperienced young person who I think
we said new experiences not sure how to
I don't know we say live life or be
responsible adults so would it be an
accurate statement or if you however you
want to make this a question but so the
most naive people going to UNH as
freshmen and sophomores they are
contained within the
dorm uh housing right they so then the
more responsible ones theoretically of
course as Juniors and seniors are the
ones seeking the house that we're
looking at in this Bill yes that is
correct although it is the first time
they've ever entered into a lease and
really lived on their own when they're
in a dormatory they're really kind of
taken care of thank you representative
hick thank you um so zoning often we
talk about health and safety as the
reason for zoning would you say on
average there's a difference um in
health and safety between a a family or
let's say adults regardless of family
status adults living in housing versus
um undergraduate students regardless of
whether they are legally
adults yes in U as Brendan oin our fire
Mall noted the fire code recognizes this
as well and typically if someone is in a
family unit whatever that family unit is
comprised of those individuals know each
other they care about one another they
know another's schedules um and if there
was a fire or an issue they have concern
and they're going to look out for one
another's welfare where if you have
individuals who are not connected in
that way living together they don't know
their comies and goes they don't
necessarily have any connections if
there's an emergency they're off they're
on they're leaving they're not concerned
about others in the property per
se so yes and all right other questions
all right you're off the hook
for now I'll be right here if you need
me thank
Berlin got some things to pass out here
so just give me a minute I'll start
help you feed the other side um we'll
just go down this way make sure everyone
you
something
okay everybody got that
um so my name is Jeff Berlin I uh
introduced this bill last year as 1281
with uh we had a bipartisan group last
year um full of progressive people on
the left and Libertarians on the right
um and the actions that you've seen uh
introduced at the Town level by Al your
truly Allen Howland you have that um
that they've just just been discussing
in front of you right now so you can
actually see it um
their actions were a direct result of
what we introduced last year I take it
as sort of capitulation that we had a
pretty big issue that we brought in
front of the state because at the local
level we were not able to make any
progress for obvious reasons as you just
witnessed I think the best arguments
from our side to be honest with you is
to just listen to what these people are
saying they're basically requesting you
to uphold their discrimination in the
name of I think Todd just said some kids
walk home at night and wake up the whole
neighborhood I've never seen that happen
but apparently Todd has um I equate it
similarly to you know I live in the
downtown area and um huge dog lover
myself but I have to say we have some
neighbors who let their dogs out at 6:00
in the morning and they bark non-stop
and they literally wake up the whole
neighborhood I haven't seen anybody try
to introduce local legislation to ban
dogs being outside at 7 the morning as
this inconvenience and um although if
they did at least they wouldn't be
manipulating the housing market which is
basically what is happening with this
local zoning so um I think that's some
important notes I'd like to just
highlight some things on the map here so
if you look at this map this is the
downtown Zone in um in
Durham and we have two different things
here so on this map um the black line
that goes straight through is I didn't
really introduce myself completely so I
am a citizen of Derm and a landlord I'm
I manage um private off-campus housing
of others I also have a small portfolio
of individual um properties most of
which are actually grandfathered which
is part of the problem um and are
scattered throughout Durham that are
actually outside of this map so I in
certain properties I'm not subject to
this unrelated rule for whatever reason
from a long time ago so the black line
going through this um is on the left
side is my opinion and my expertise of
where students would prefer to live in
town um the circled zones are the ones
that Durham just capitulated um to our
issue and now they're saying that the
commercial use of quote unquote a
student rental
um they've shown you it's an industrial
use so they want the students to live in
the industrial zones and the um CU
that's what they think of them
apparently is that they're industrial
use maybe I don't know um the X's that
I've put which is sort of the most
egregious part right so in the new Z in
the new amendment that Al introduced at
Durham I think they're leaving out that
this student rental is not allowed in
one of the closest residential zones to
campus and so on the bottom left of this
map I have marked on it's Mill Road it's
the right side of mil Road and durm so
those of you who are familiar would know
this these properties literally touch
campus and in the ones I've exed out are
to my best knowledge houses that if were
they were allowed to rent to more than
three now four
unrelated have bedrooms that are vacant
currently and would be added to the
market if you accept this
bill now if you just start doing that
throughout all the yellow zones on this
map that is the visual effect of the
Supply that was removed via this
discriminatory and restrictive
zoning if you're serious
about the fact that you have a housing
crisis and that it's exacerbated by
restrictive zoning and an under
Supply we have a solution for you right
here now people get worried that it's
going to be a free-for-all around town
and you're going to have a frat house in
the neighborhood here and a sorority in
the neighborhood here
unfortunately you know and from my
perspective we don't have enough
students to actually make that happen so
if you moved every single student out of
oncampus
Housing and whether they're
undergraduate overgrad duate and just
moved them into the
neighborhoods there's not enough of them
to do what they're asking to do what
they're trying to tell you is going to
happen and
so I would just argue that that is sort
of muddying the waters I think the
amendment that uh rep howand is also
introducing just like last year I think
is designed to confuse people this is
not a fire safety bill this is a
Equitable housing Bill and so I'd ask
you not to confuse those two
things Mr burlin we just ask you wrap up
if you yeah sure so yep I'll wrap up
right now so um if you have any
questions I'll answer them but I would
say that if you if you let this bill go
through what's you're going to see
happen is you're going to see students
move from the right side of this black
line on your map to the left side and
for no discussions at the Town level or
anything regarding Workforce housing
you're going to create the workforce
housing because you're going to remove
the demand for the grandfathered
properties where students current live
outside of town as they move forward
you're going to open that up for the
workforce thank you and free to answer
any questions thank you questions for Mr
Berlin representative Howland I just
have one because you mentioned that the
zones that you'd circled were were zoned
industrial and that's where we're having
students live that that does not
actually appear to be the case actually
CB is Central Business business CH is
courthouse and C is co those are
actually uh the central business
district a residential area budding the
central district and another residential
so they're they're not industrial at all
is that is that true
um so yeah I see one res I mean
professional office and Central Business
I think is I've heard described as
business and okay so may maybe I haven't
heard that
um you guys can decide if you think that
the segregation of students to the
middle of where the businesses are is
industrial or commercial in nature or
mean I just follow up so that white area
that's in the middle of your circled
areas that's unh's campus right the
white area is the central business
district the um the legend I think the
circle CB is Central District central
business district but the white area
that AB buts that that that's next to
the green area that you have is that un
campus I'm not sure what you're talking
about the the grided area that's unh's
campus that's what I'm say map I'm
asking yeah yeah that's what yeah that's
what it
says and I I went and I went there and
I'm trying to like understand like
where's Paul College compared to like
this map I I'm sorry this this is a
zoning map that's the only reason sorry
it's like unless you're really familiar
with Derm zoning
unfortunately uh the map is not as
helpful um we can always go over it
later great yes we can all right other
questions from Mr
Berlin San thank you very much thank you
Kimble
welcome you're on red is on uh just turn
it on you're off now you're on now I'm
on okay great um all right well I
appreciate uh the attention of the
committee um my name is Stephen Kimble I
um my family has owned property in
Durham for over 90 years we've lived on
that property for four generations and
uh I uh am just a private citizen
essentially but um when I heard what
Durham was doing uh I was so uh
concerned with it that I felt I should
get involved um fundamentally you know
we've heard a lot of smooth talking
bureaucrats trying to make this all
sound normal but if you boil it down
right the 14th Amendment says equal
protection under the law and just
because there hasn't been a landmark
Supreme Court case about discriminating
against students doesn't mean they don't
deserve equal protection under the law
um and but the Supreme Court has made it
clear that separate but equal doesn't
cut it equal is equal so um I think that
any zoning ordinance that's allowed to
use the characteristics of the people in
the housing as a way to segregate them
into different parts of town is just
fundamentally wrong and not supported in
the law and I think that that you should
be very careful if you're going to allow
that to continue um the property that we
have there uh back in 1935 my
grandfather uh he was a university
professor and he allowed uh students to
to build a cabin in behind his house cuz
during the Great Depression there was
really no housing for for students and
uh and so that's how we came to have two
houses on one lot and um we've always
done that uh maintain it sometimes it's
rented to students sometimes we have
families in there um sometimes our
family uses one of the houses sometimes
we rent it out it's just it's been there
and we've always had the flexibility to
do what needed to be done with it uh we
were free to choose who our tenants were
we were free to manage them in the way
we chose to and that uh is the right
thing to do um that kind of generosity
really could never happen today of of
building another building on your
property to uh to help house
students um one of the things that I
really found concerning is is their use
of the US Department of Education
definition of a student uh to define a
class to segregate into a different part
of town I mean that definition was
created to identify people that that
they wanted to support and encourage to
pursue higher education to better
themselves these are our future leaders
these are people that we're looking to
support not to segregate off into some
commercial Zone because nobody wants to
deal with their learning experience or
or their
education um I would have to say uh if
you replace the word student with any
other class of people I think you would
find it highly offensive I mean if you
try this is their de this is their
definition with the word student
replaced immigrant rental an immigrant
rental is a residential dwelling
composed of one or more dwelling units
on a single parcel that includes five or
more immigrants as defined by federal
law immigrant rentals are not allowed
use in any residential district r r a RB
or
RC they could pass that tomorrow under
the zoning ordinance we have does
anybody think that we should allow local
zoning officials to have the power to
regulate in that fashion
I'm just ask Mr Kimble if you wrap up
that'd be great yep
um all right well I don't think it was
ever the intention of the state zoning
law or or that it's a covered purpose
under RSA 67417 to enable local and
Municipal zoning officials to delve into
the private lives of their residents in
order to segregate them into different
groups with different rights and
privileges with respect to housing
options um while uh representative
howland's uh attempt at incorporating
the state fire code AS a remedy uh is
admirable I think it misses the Mark if
you read the definition in there
carefully uh it says by members of a
single family with not more than three
Outsiders in rented rooms so I see huge
loopholes I see a fraternity brother
who's done well for himself buying a
house and letting a dozen of his younger
fraternity Brothers live there for free
and this would simply not apply the fire
code wouldn't apply so I don't think
it's the remedy everybody's hoping it's
going to be I think you should go with
the language that is in the bill perhaps
augmented with some language to expand
it more clearly that they're not to
discriminate on educational status or
familial status or any other basis
People Are People let them live in
housing thank you thank you for your
testimony questions for Mr
Kimble seeing represent Reed thank you
Mr chair um thank you very much for your
poignant testimony I uh wasn't able to
ask this question of a previous speaker
so I'll ask it of you um do you
understand what I heard previously was
that they're trying to uh get at certain
behaviors that are problematic and I
guess my question is um actually Mr
chair I just lost my train of thought
okay well if there's if there's no other
questions thank you Mr Sor I'll ask you
personally thank you there's plenty of
Dees welcome
back thank you now we're talking
congregate housing rather than Farms we
had a lot of discussion about
agricultural use earlier on that other
bill um for the record my name is bro
Dees I work with the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association um and I'm here to an
opposition on behalf of nire Municipal
Association for House Bill uh
457 so one thing I do want to flag is
that the municipal and County government
committee is currently has a work
session scheduled for tomorrow um to do
with recovery homes House Bill uh 432
which would be another um zoning mandate
similar to this one that would impact
congregate living and how congregate
living is regulated in municipalities
under their zoning um ordinances
specifically um when you have that
occupancy threshold per per room or just
per dwelling that um that's met and then
there's a change of use for the
structure for the uh dwelling unit so
it's important to really delineate the
difference between congregate versus
regular dwelling units so regular
dwelling unit has everything that you
need in a dwelling unit like a kitchen
you know proper waste disposal um you
know running water you know bedrooms
living space Etc congregate living is
different in the nature of that you have
separate bedrooms that are throughout
the dwelling um but there's shared
living space there's shared facilities
for bathrooms there might be shared
kitchens um in municipalities they have
an interest for the safety health and
the general welfare of their communities
to regulate where congregate living is
in different zoning districts um the
reason for this is because different
zoning districts have been developed
over a 50 60 70 year period um to have
specific amount of infrastructure impact
um to have enough space and land for
Waste Disposal like a septic system has
sewer systems and water systems that are
built to only meet a certain capacity um
there's parking requirements to make
sure that there's enough parking
depending on the dwelling unit how many
people or how many units are in it um
traffic is a huge concern that happens
in many of these municipalities and
again waste disposal more than just you
know sewage waste and Water waste you
know there's also trash disposal you
know so um and other types of uh garbage
that people might need to have be picked
up by whether it's a municipal service
or private service
um taking a normal not a normal that's a
bad term um taking a regular dwelling
unit and changing it to congregate
housing is a change of use it would
require variance in the few
municipalities that actually do regulate
congregant living it tends to be college
towns because they have an invested
interest of making sure that you don't
have you know an inordinate amount of
people that are all unrelated trying to
live in the same space that's part of
the reason why zoning exists because we
had issues where um you know housing was
too full to capacity and it was creating
safety issues and health issues in the
municipalities and not just for those
who are residing in those units I know
you're going to tell me it's almost time
um it had an interest to further the uh
General Welfare um there is also Merit
to what was described earlier about
unrelated people behaving differently
especially if they have um separate
leases um and especially if the releases
are done by bed um you know an example
would be a a two-person family with two
kids they're not going to need as many
cars right they're not going to need a
car for every individual but for college
students they might work and they might
need to travel to school to their
classes so they're going to need a car
so you need to you know when they go
through the process of getting a
variance you might want to make a
requirement or a contingency that they
create more parking or if you all of a
sudden have like six people living in
the congrate living space you might need
to increase the septic um capacity so
then it's not um polluting the
groundwater or so it's not polluting or
the septic system doesn't fail and
pollute other people's
properties dises if you could wrap up
that'd be great my last yeah my last
comment um zoning and occupancy
ordinances help also limit the potential
of violations to noise uh noise nuisance
trash waste disposal Etc SE several
other ordinances the goal is for smart
development and reasonable development
to try to limit conflict between
Property Owners too and respect every
property owner's rights um to be able to
live peacefully in their community and
with that I'll take any
questions thank you for your testimony
representative miles thank Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question um
so would you say that regardless of
familial status
relationships would you think it's
reasonable that the the law might be two
people per bedroom just no matter what
the relationships are are would that be
reasonable well so municipalities you'd
run into major constitutional issues if
you were trying to regulate the number
of people in a dwelling You know despite
family so if they're all related you
know it can be kind of difficult to you
know to try to disentangle um trying to
regulate you know families versus
unrelated people um we think for
unrelated people I guess I should so we
think for unrelated people um the
municipalities and what we've seen and
at least what I've seen in most of the
zoning ordinances is the trigger doesn't
happen until um until you get to that
four per four different parties
unrelated or four different groups
unrelated when the fire code comes into
place um and so part of the reason is
because congregate living in a single
family residential zone is much
different it's much different and it's
higher density than what the Zone was
originally designed for or even like a
two family so um I guess I'm kind of
confused by your question if you couldif
uh I'll put it more simply is it
unreasonable to have a minimum uh or is
it unreasonable in any circumstance to
have two people no matter what their
relationship is per bedroom in a house
three three bedrooms two people per
bedroom is that
unreasonable to have an to come up to a
total of six people per that particular
house if there's three bedrooms six
unrelated people like why is that a
problem it would it would depend on the
specific zoning district and the
specific municipality whether or not
that's an issue and that's why it's best
to leave it as a local decision
something that the municipality has
control over because you're right there
could be in a situation where you have a
you know someone gets a variance to do
conget living in a multif family um
zoning District where they have all the
infrastructure and all the parking
Arrangements necessary to facilitate
having six people that could have up to
six cars that they need to park and to
have the infrastructure
the ability to do with the waste water
but I know where I live in Wolf bro
there are some zoning districts where
that just wouldn't be feasible it two
people per bedroom in in a house that
has three bedrooms that wouldn't be
feasible yeah okay thank
you represent
buolo thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony um previously on an unrelated
bill I asked you about fair housing and
if I recall your response was something
like oh well that never happens and
I look at this current situation going
on in this current bill and that thing
that never happens looks like it's
happening it looks like there is a town
that is discriminating based on familial
status regardless of how the current you
know New Hampshire Supreme Court has
ruled on ordinances like this there
worth practices in the past such as red
lining which at the time were legal but
later on were found to be illegal so my
question is does the New Hampshire
Municipal Association support support
discriminating in zoning no no we don't
we don't support um discrimination in
zoning ordinances it's illegal can I
follow let finish I'd like to yeah I
appreciate it Mr chairman thank you um
look we're treating it doesn't matter
the status of the person what matters is
that the change that there's a change of
use of the dwelling that's the only
thing from the municipality standpoint
that it's regulating is what the usage
is that's happening on that lot and with
that build and so when you go from a
regular dwelling unit and turn it into
congregate housing it's much different
in the type of Housing and it needs to
be regulated much differently depending
on the zoning district and so it's not a
discrimination against people it's
treating different uses differently like
we do in all of our zoning ordinances
throughout the state so you know it's
like treating a a two family um dwelling
in a two family Zone differently than a
one family dwelling in a single
zone so let's do do a hypothetical then
talking about the different uses let's
say all right you have a thin line go
ahead okay I'm sorry let me ask maybe a
more in a more direct way if there's a
if there is a home that has a single
bedroom and there are two people living
in that home and there is another home
with a single bedroom and two people
living in that home how is the use
different well you're not changing the
the usage it sounds like in both cases
use well the difference is is one of one
of those homes is occupied by two
students who are unrelated and one of
those homes is occupied by people who
happen to be legally married is the use
still different well because that's a
residential use but we're talking about
congregate living situations and
congregate living is different than
single family residential it's treated
differently it's a different use and
additionally in DM's case it becomes a
commercial once you're leasing It Out by
bedroom so yeah it is it is a different
use I know I had a long conversation for
an hour with um some of the public
health Advocates over at New Futures
while we're trying to work through this
recovery homes Bill to try to explain
like the change of use isn't necessarily
who's using it it's how it's being used
so if you're using it as single family
residential then the municipalities and
their zoning ordinances if that's Zone
if that zoning District permits it they
don't have a problem the problem becomes
once it starts to become you know you're
packing a lot of people into congregate
living into a lot of rooms and then you
have larger issues that could impact the
people living in the dwelling and those
who are budding the dwelling and other
people in the community too because of
the infrastructure impact and services
impact what if if we legalize polygamy
and we say eight students could get
married and live in one house that would
that would be okay we'd run into well it
would it wouldn't change the use because
it's a single family
right it's one family of eight people
that's an interesting hypothetical uh no
I guess I'm wondering what the
difference if you bring forward that
bill next year we'd have to raise some
of the housing concerns that would be
impacted by that but I'm just just
trying to follow along no I I I see your
point but like that's you know it's kind
of that's so far out of the realm of
conceivably what would ever happen in
the state and what would be permitted
and how our laws would be you know set
up we're we're what we're trying to do
is make sure that congrate living
situations are in zones where they're
permitted and that they're put in proper
zones that have the infrastructure and
the capacity to handle those congrate
living situations the adequate parking
the proper traffic patterns that
sometimes they need to be near like
public transit has been mentioned so
again we can't we don't want to treat
congregate living the same as single
family living I I see your point um but
I I think it's kind of a moot point
because the legislature isn't going to I
mean fingers crossed the legislature
won't be legalizing polygamy any time
soon personal opinion of mine but you
know we're just trying to figure out the
best way to reasonably responsibly Zone
communities that respect the landowner
respect the occupants if it's not the
landowner and that respects the abutters
in the entire Community that's that's
the goal thank you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um I have a
question and then a followup regarding
congregated housing um were you
referring to the type of housing
described in HB 432 that is recovery
housing were you referring to that that
type of housing as congregate housing
and I should full disclosure here um I'm
the prime sponsor of HB
432 were you describing that as concrete
at housing in many zoning ordinances
throughout the state recovery homes or
recovery houses as defined in RSA 153
col 10-d Roman 2 they fall under um
congregate housing zoning ordinances
typically are you aware that
followup um that there is a federal
definition of congregate housing and I
don't have it memorized but it refers to
much larger housing developments and not
at all to the type of small group um
housing for people with disabilities as
is described in HB 432 it's a totally
different animal um I was aware but it's
based on like I'll give an example the
example is the city of Kean city of keen
has a congregate house in ordinance and
then it defines all the different types
of housing that fall under that Conger
housing and they tend to be like
fraternities sororities recovery houses
um you know group living and so they
make sure essentially it's like well if
you're going to change the use we want
to make sure that you have the adequate
infrastructure to accompany the change
of use to accompany the conget housing
so then it's not a negative detriment to
those who are Butters the rest of the
community and so then people can safely
live in them um so we are I know we have
a work session tomorrow for your bill so
we're going to be talking about a lot of
those things in regards to recovery
housings but a lot of it is um let's um
let's keep it focused to the say a lot
of that a lot of thank you
representative Gibbs you can talk to Mr
Des about that later representative Reed
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um so to piggyback off the
last question the federal definition of
congregate housing is specifically low
rent housing for people who need help
with daily activities such as cooking
and personal care so while conce
um a recovery house might fall under
that I don't think student housing does
and and this is getting to the point and
the question that I keep trying to ask
and I keep not hearing a real answer it
sounds like congregate housing is now
the veil under which we are
discriminating against a entire group of
people because we think they don't fit
in because they have these problematic
behaviors but we all know that the
single family houses have the same
behaviors the students there are plenty
of students who study and are quiet so
why isn't the op the the correct
solution to Simply enforce your noise
ordinances your garbage ordinances and
not take an entire group of people and
say they are the problem because we
think we have a stigma that they engage
in those types of behaviors more than
other people why isn't the noise
ordinance and the garbage ordinance and
all those things the solution to your
supposed problem instead of taking an
entire class of people and treating them
differently um I would say that
congregate so first congregate housing
as defined in the city of keen zoning
ordinances is unrelated to the federal
definition that's just what they call
congr housing those types of group
living situations and there different
types of housing that would fall under
that so it's those are you know while
it's the same term Conger housing it's
two very different governments doing
very different things without definition
um my point isn't you know I'm not
intimately aware of all the things that
are happening in Durham where they're
trying to enforce ordinances and the
exact minutia of the different updates
they've made to their zoning ordinances
what I'm speaking to is reasonable
responsible development and making sure
that when there's a change of use that
communities have the tools to ensure
that the proper infrastructure exists
for that change of use the adequate
parking spaces the proper um um uh
traffic pattern the waste disposal that
those types of things can be included
when they apply for the variance and so
it's not against students because anyone
could live in a congregate living
situation this entire committee could
decide it wants to live in a congregate
living situation if it wants to you know
and you would have to go depending on
where it is I know it would be an
interesting house wouldn't it um but
this you would have to go to your to
your zoning board and apply for a
variance if it was in an area that
wasn't zoned for congregate living so I
mean that's the thing it's not about
students it's about congregate living as
a whole and making sure that
municipalities are ensuring that these
types of uses are done in zoning
districts where it's reasonable to the
people living in them the people who own
whole then I'll give
up so I keep hearing I didn't hear an
answer to why the enforcing the noise
ordinances wasn't the solution but I'll
I'll I'll move to on to this change of
use concept and I'm really struggling to
understand why you continually call
congregate housing but we are saying
that seems to be a totally different
thing and I don't know K's not here with
us today so I can't speak for Keen but
this change of use people living in a
house is a residential use all of this
is residential it's not a change of use
it's not so like it's literally it's not
commercial right it's people who need to
live and why is we're talking about
these problematic behaviors right but
the behavior that we're talking about
here is living just living sleeping in a
bedroom representative ask a
question I think I we understand we
understand your I understand how is it a
change of use if what we're not we're
not talking about people who need
assistance but we're talking about
people sleeping in bedrooms and how is
that going to help the situation with
your with your Workforce housing when
you're literally keeping people from
accessing lower uh cost housing because
you're saying that somehow living
together where it's cheaper is a change
of use when you're just living in a
place okay so first let me address the
first thing that you mentioned which is
zoning and occupancy ordinances they
they exist to help limit the potential
violations to no noise nuisance trash
waste disposal etc those other
ordinances and it's expensive to try to
enforce all those ordinances so by
making sure that the zoning districts
that the uses conform it's to limit
those things and it's to limit the
impact on other property owners who are
going to be the ones you know the ones
who aren't living in the property that
could be having these violations they're
the ones who call and get upset and
there's an expectation that their Town
reacts to you know to their call and
their request to enforce ordinances and
that's expensive um the goal of zoning
ordinances is to prevent those things
from happening that is that and the
health safety and that's where the
general welfare part comes in now
regarding change of use you could change
the use to commercial if you're leasing
it out the space um in most situations
though the change of use is because
you've gone from a single family
dwelling unit where everything that you
need in the dwelling unit the places
where you sleep your waste disposal the
kitchen bathrooms other amenities your
waste disposal waste water and other
waste that's all part of the unit right
it's like you know so when you go to
congregate living though there are
shared communal spaces for using the
bathroom there shared communal spaces
for using the kitchen um it's like the
difference between my house or someone's
apartment in a college dorm and
municipalities have an interest in
regulating that congregate living
differently than regular um Zone than
regular dwelling units they're just very
different um types of use yes they're
both used in a way where people are
living and sleeping and eating and
breathing and hanging out and doing
their thing studying going to work but
the use is still different just by the
very nature of How It's utilized and how
The Residency operates and the types of
people who are in those types of
congrate living situations it's very
it's very distinct okay okay we've been
going an hour and a half on this I'm
going to hope that if there's a question
that hasn't been asked yet I will also
behave but if there's a question that
hasn't been asked yet feel free to ask
it I don't want to limit anybody but um
let's be cognizant of time
representative Axton go
ahead I I I may have missed the answer
to this question representative Reed
asked you why do your existing
ordinances on trash collection
maintenance Etc why would they why do
they not
work on this type of
housing they work they work so they work
to the best of their ability right so
obviously if someone's VI I mean
congrate housing creates the kind of
environment sometimes where like any
high density areas where there's just
additional waste and there's additional
um you know people living closer
together so the noise impacts other
people um more so the nature of it is
that there will be more calls and it
will be more administra it will be more
work for the municipality to be able to
enforce its zoning ordinances and
sometimes there's an interest to not
have coner housing in a single family um
residential Zone because one it's a
totally different type of use but two to
limit the number of ordinance violations
so they don't have to be going out to
the same property getting the same calls
and it's not just about students I
really want to make that clear too it's
about just the nature of the use being
different and how it could impact the
number of calls and number of zoning or
sorry not zoning ordinance number of
ordinance violations for those types of
things so um I hope that answers your
question I I just think the type of
housing begets you know possibility of
or increases the possibility of
ordinances being violated so follow up
follow up so just so I'm clear what
you're really saying what your answer
boils down to if I understand you
correctly is that this is not a matter
of it's not that your existing rules
don't work it's that you'd have to
enforce them no it's that's not my
answer my answer is that there would be
more cases of violation and more needing
to enforce them and that creates stress
and strain on
municipalities okay representative
Gibbs thank you I'll try and be brief as
I can um okay suppose I have a large
four-bedroom house and I have a husband
and six children that's eight people
living in a four-bedroom house with one
bathroom and one kitchen Shar and don't
say that's impossible because that's how
I grew up um low-income people have to
live that way all the time y
um okay then suppose I am a disabled
person never mind recovery housing just
any kind of disability and I want to
live with seven other disabled people so
we can help each other out in that same
four bedroomroom house how is that a
change of use because by having by
having it exceed the amount of the
unrelated parties or the unre unrelated
people who are living there you've now
kind of kicked in where fire codes now
come into play and municipalities have
an interest in saying well that's a
congre living situation now versus a
single family uh residential dwelling
and by the very nature as we kind of
discuss unrelated people they behave
differently especially depending on what
their lease Agreements are and that has
an impact on the neighborhoods and the
municipality and the zoning District um
it would be I mean we'd be essentially
saying um with this bill that that
municipalities have zero interest in in
regulating um congregate living
situations when very clearly there's
a that's fine um when when they clearly
do have an interest to promote the
general welfare the safety and the
health of
folks but never mind follow followup
thank you never mind um what you call it
okay and for the moment let's not think
about the fire code because remember the
the number of people is the same M okay
so if there's going to be a fire the
number of people who are going to be
burned down is the same mhm okay so for
practical purposes regardless of what
you call it okay whether you call it
congr housing or whatever you call it
how is that a change of
use because it's no longer single family
residential it's now congregate like
that's the very essence of what we're
kind of discussing and like for example
congreg
comes with their because of the way it's
used and because of the very nature of
it like for example your family I I can
assume growing up didn't have a car for
every single individual but in many
congrate living situations it's ideal
for people to each have a car because
they're not all working at the same
place and it's not always feasible for
them to all carpool together so just by
that very nature if someone were to
change your single family dwelling um
unit to a congrate living situation A a
um zba a zoning Board of adjustment
might say well you need to make sure you
increase your parking capacity you might
need to build a parking lot and oh yeah
you need to make sure it meets the
current traffic patterns it's just it's
it becomes so much different than just
if I have a kid tomorrow right or if I
have 10 kids tomorrow that I decide to
adopt me and my wife aren going to have
more than two cars we're still going to
have two cars in our single family
residential home in our village district
is zoned in a way where I have two
parking spots that are on my property
for me and probably run into an issue in
the future where I need to get a third
or a fourth car for kids if I had 10 of
them but still the municip ipal is going
to say well you can't park on the side
of the road and so just just things like
that this bill doesn't consider and it
takes a tool away from municipalities to
be able to have reasonable zoning
regulations that help everyone coexist
in a community uh further very brief
um but isn't that your assumption of how
people are going to act I mean is that
based on any kind of a study or any kind
of demographic information we I've heard
a lot of assumptions about how people
act and how different kinds of people
act and I'm not sure how much um basis
it has I think by the very by the very
fact that these zoning ordinances exist
is because of real world problems that
happened in the municipalities where
they said we need to find a way to
regulate this so we can balance the
needs of those who are trying to live in
the style of Housing and the needs of
those in the community and the
infrastructure Capac capity that exists
in that community so um I have heard of
real world examples in our cities and I
think Durham brought up some some real
world examples of how Conger housing is
just different in nature than the
residential use um committee members are
more than fine to disagree with this I'm
just representing our municipalities and
what they've told me and what they have
me share with you um to the best of my
ability so I think he's answered he's
answered it as best as he can thank you
representative
reinford thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so who is it that
is enforcing this by door knocking to
see if representative Alexander married
eight of his roommates or representative
Gibbs um changed the people that are
living with her to the disability
Community or that the students actually
have another College um student move in
who's actually doing the door knocking
to enforce this um well it's not like
they're going around and knocking on
every single door so I don't want people
to think that municipalities are basic
like hey you know like your ra like hey
you know dorm check how many people are
in your dorm tonight you know it's past
quiet hours like that's not happening
but you know they get calls from people
that say hey there's like eight people
living in the single family residence n
of them seem related and they're parking
all over the street and they're parking
in front of my house or maybe they're
parking my driveway so you know a code
enforcement officer or someone from the
fire department or someone from the
planning department might go out and be
like hey how many people are living in
this residence who are unrelated and
then they might say oh it ceeds what's
required in this um in this residential
district or it might you know be in
violation of fire code and then they
have to work with the property owner and
those who are you know inhabiting the
dwelling um to figure out how to get
them in compliance and it's supposed to
be a collaborative process followup okay
um so basically what you're saying um or
are is what you're saying that basically
taxpayers are are paying for their own
discrimination against their own people
no T because there is no discrimination
that's happening it's just just change
of use so the taxpayers are not funding
any discrimination the taxpayers are
funding um the enforcement of the voter
adopted zoning ordinances and respecting
the will of the voters the same voters
who pay taxes so thank you so that would
not be my interpretation I'm sorry
representative representative miles
thank you I'm just want would you
would I'm wondering if there's any
property owners in the zoning areas that
are you
know we're talking about today in this
bill I wonder if any of those Property
Owners feel like this is an infringement
on their property
rights um I would personally believe
that they would go and vote for the
zoning ordinances that they support to
allow permitted uses whether it's in
their zones or others that the community
feels is most appropriate for making
sure that People's Health safety General
Welfare um and the balance of you know
private property ownership rights and um
and Municipal um requirements to help
promote General Welfare so I think
that's I think voting is the best way in
dealing with this and I think local
control is the best way to allow for
local go sorry local public bodies the
legislative bodies to decide what kinds
of powers and what kinds of regulations
their municipality is going to have to
deal with these types of
situations representative Reed thank
thank you Mr chair I really appreciate
it thank you for taking my question
again so what I've heard is that the
reason that the ordinances around noise
and garbage are not the solution to the
problem is because it's expensive to do
the enforcement so my question is do you
believe that a university brings in lots
of business into a community that the
students patronize the local businesses
and entire businesses and districts of
businesses pop up around the university
bringing in Revenue to that town and if
you do believe that as I do why isn't
the increased cost of of enforcement the
fair trade-off for that community that
gets a benefit from that University well
as I've previously mentioned the zoning
ordinances that exists that when
enforced and when abided by they're
supposed to limit all those things so
then that investment can be made towards
other things that are important in the
community and growing the general
welfare like for example education I
mean you don't want to be funneling all
year and remember it's property taxes so
just because a lot of college students
are going to a bar a lot of that bar
Revenue the business tax revenue all of
it actually goes to the state it's just
the property taxes that assess value it
does change with the real estate market
but it's not like all of a sudden
because a business is highly frequented
by any population of people that that
means that you know all of a sudden
they're going to have to pay more
property taxes um so the reality is is
that these towns are squeezed they have
very tight budgets they're working their
hardest to enforce existing ordinances
and zoning ordinances exist as a way to
prevent these neighborly conflicts and
to prevent these these um ordinance
violations and so they're trying their
hardest to enforce them with the
resources that they have and the zoning
ordinances exist and the reason why the
state law permits municipalities to have
these zoning ordinances is to make it so
that these other ordinances aren't
constantly being violated because
there're people who are just in
disagreement over you know even things
like parking parking is such a big thing
that in high density communities or high
population communities gets people
really really at each other so you know
just making there's adequate parking is
than you thank you for testifying on the
bill regarding parking we're going to
keep it to the well just thank you I
appreciate it all right seeing no other
questions thank
Sasso and I just um am reminded that to
stay within three minutes if
possible good afternoon honorable
members
sorry good afternoon honorable committee
members my name is Patrick Sasso I am
currently a sophomore at the University
of New Hampshire I am here today in
support of House Bill
457 um sorry so what's sorry I'm here to
talk about something that's affecting
the students and Durham which is uh zon
and laws keeping rent rental prices
artificially high rent prices are out of
control and they average around
$2,925 a month which is about 50% higher
than the national average this is
because of the student discrimination
laws that allow only three unrelated
people to live together in Durham House
Bill 457 is a simple fix it gets rid of
these outdated rules and lets landlords
and tenants make their own decisions
about housing instead of the government
deciding who can live where it will make
housing more affordable help students
and give young professionals more
options in a market that desperately
needs it but instead of supporting this
much-needed change the Durham Town
Council is fighting to preserve
traditional neighborhoods this forces
the assumption that students aren't a
part of the community of Durham we live
work and contribute to this town just
like everyone else so I'm asking you
today vote OTP for on HB 4557 help us
fix this broken system support Fair
affordable housing and recognize that
students just like everyone else deserve
a place to live thank you thank you for
following directions and being a model
member of society I appreciate that
thank you so much are there questions
for um Mr Sasso representative buolo
thank you so much for your testimony um
so in some of the other testimony I
heard I heard a lot of times College um
college students referred to as kids
college kids um my question to you is
are you an adult legally and are you
capable of entering into contracts such
as lease agreements I am legally an
adult I am 20 years old and I believe
any other questions seeing none thank
botin welcome thank you good afternoon
honorable committee members my name is
Elliot boen and I'm here before you as a
UNH student and I'm here to advocate for
House Bill 457 a bill that is essential
to restoring fairness and affordability
to D students housing market I want to
share the story of my friend Mark
riggers a sophomore at the University of
New Hampshire who like many students was
blocked from securing off-campus housing
last year to Durham's outdated
discriminatory zoning laws marking a
group of friends out early to find
private housing for their junior year
they planned they budgeted they searched
through every available listing
eventually they found a house that
seemed like the perfect fit for bedroom
home close to campus within their
financial means but when they went to
close the deal the landlord said they
could only rent to three students due to
DM's three unrelated rule under this law
no more than three unrelated well we
know all that either one
person the group had to face an
impossible choice either one person had
to drop out and find another group last
minute or they had to give up the house
altogether for Mark this rule made
housing unaffordable splitting rent
fourways was within his budget but
dividing it by three made it impossible
the extra cost forced him and his
friends to abandon their search for
private housing and stay on campus with
the combination of dorm uh dorm rent
meal plans and parking permits often
cost more than the off-campus housing
itself Mark situation is not unique is
happening to hundreds if not thousands
of students every year Durham zoning
laws artificially restrict housing
supply near campus driving up costs and
making it harder for students to find
reasonable living options as Jeffrey B L
point out in his recent opad the
economics of the rule are very clear if
you restrict Supply but demand stands
the same prices go up and more students
are allowed to rent homes based on the
number of bedrooms now arbitrary zoning
rules rents would naturally decrease
instead these restrictions benefit
wealthy landlords and large
institutional property owners who profit
from keeping housing options limited
durm officials argue that they're just
trying to preserve the character of the
neighborhoods like we've heard today but
let's be honest it's not about
complaints or safety the town has
already has rules to handle these issues
this is about pushing the students out
making it hard for them to live
affordably and making the housing market
closed off to those who need it most is
fundamentally unfair that forworking
responsible adults cannot legally rent a
four-bedroom home simply because they're
students if this rule was applied to any
other demographic young professionals
relocated workers or military personnel
there would be immediate blacklash this
is why House Bill 457 must pass House
Bill 457 would put an end to this
discrimination and ensure that housing
laws were based on fairness non-
outdated biases against students it
would open up the market allowing
students like Mark and other many others
to opportunity to live where they can
afford rather than being forced in
financial hardship or staying in
overpriced campus housing students are a
part of the community we contribute to
Durham's economy its culture and its
future it's time for durm to stop
treating students like Outsiders and
start treating them like the residents
they are passing House Bill 4557 isn't
just about housing it's about fairness
affordability and the right to live
where you can afford I urge you support
House Bill 457 let's fix this thank you
very much thank you Mr botin questions
representative miles and represent Allen
thank you um at the beginning can you
just um clarify did you say that the
property owner wanted to rent to the
four but his property rights were
infringed upon absolutely thank you
it's a great question represent howand
did so did you speak out uh when UNH
then because you're talking about
affordability but UNH then passed a
requirement that made sophomores live on
campus so did you speak out against UNH
for the extra cost that it would impose
upon students making it less affordable
then I was not on campus at that point
so I was able to do it follow but I
would have just to follow up so since
you are on campus now now are you active
in speaking out against UN about the
increased requirement because it's
yes well okay that comes back to the The
Freshman sopore rule I believe in free
market housing I believe in just ending
discrimination policies based on just an
arbitr relationship rule the the just
the fact that
we're unrelated doesn't mean the
requirements change for the house itself
if the the safeties there the fire
safety is there there's like no reason
if the landlord himself agrees to
renting to that status people are
people other questions seeing on thank
you Mr
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
here today my name is Sarah Scott and
I'm with Americans for Prosperity here
in New Hampshire uh I'm here today to
testify in support of House Bill 457
which seeks to prohibit local zoning
ordinances from limiting the number of
occupants in a dwelling unit to fewer
than two per bedroom and from
restricting occupancy based on familial
status uh as was mentioned recently
these regulations infringe upon Property
Owners rights to utilize the property as
they see fit and often lead to increased
housing costs by artificially limiting
housing availability by removing these
constraints Property Owners will have
greater freedom and the housing market
can better respond to the diverse needs
of our community New Hampshire faces a
significant challenge in retaining young
people many are leaving due to high
housing costs and limited avail ility
partly driven by restrictive zoning laws
I grew up in New Hampshire and watched
as many of my childhood friends and
friends from college were forced to
leave the state uh due to the high cost
of housing this is something that my
family is facing right now as uh one of
my sisters who stayed in New Hampshire
for college and planned to stay
Hereafter is now looking at the housing
market and realizing that even with a
job she can't afford rent on her own um
I think the days of having one roommate
and being able to afford rent are over
and there are a lot of young people that
are graduating and still looking for
jobs or taking lower paying jobs that
are not able to afford rent by easing
the restrictive regulations through HB
457 we can increase housing options in
affordability making our state more
attractive to Young professionals and
college students and this not only helps
retain our youth but stimulates economic
growth and Community Vitality so we
think this is a crucial step forward and
and uh urge you to support this Bill
thank you thank you for your testimony
questions for Miss
Hooper thank you Mr chair members of the
committee again Samuel Hooper with the
institute for justice um speaking in
support of this bill um I think I
believe that the co-sponsor jokingly
referred to the bill as the Frat House
bill which um and obviously there is a
strong student Veil but one could also
call it I suppose the sitcom bill and we
think of all our favorites you know
friends Big Bang Theory How I Met Your
Mother Golden Girls you know all of them
you know perhaps idealized versions of
American Life at certain times and all
of them depicting people at different
stages and phases of life you know
utilizing housing as they see best
whether it's for companionship to save
money to combat the loneliness epidemic
you know things that were as relevant in
the 1970s as they are now but a lot more
now given the house prices are a lot
more expensive um I wanted to talk just
a little bit about the legal part of
this because um I think the um the moral
question the free market question and
the housing crisis elements have all
been discussed quite a lot so I would
just like to talk about um the fact that
um you know legally restrictions on
roommate Agreements are generally
disfavored in the courts um it varies
Circuit by Circuit in the ninth circuit
though there was um quite a compelling
um statement made in the case Fair
Housing Council of San Fernando Valley
versus roommate.com um where the court
said the right of intimate Association
isn't restricted exclusively to family
and the roommate relationship easily
qualifies um and while the Supreme Court
has generally um um hasn't looked at the
qu the question for a while but has in
the past upheld restrictions on the man
the number of unrelated people living
together it has also um it has also
cracked down on unduly um narrow
definitions of what actually constitutes
a family and I provided some citations
in my written testimony that I'll submit
to the committee as well generally
speaking House Bill 457 is a good step
toward preserving and restoring property
rights which we strongly support um and
promoting free market Housing Solutions
avoiding the need for kind of more
heavy-handed government intervention I
did want to just reot one um piece of um
testimony from a previous witness
talking about the fact that if you have
more density and you allow this kind of
housing then it can increase the cost of
providing services and I think you know
waste collection and garbage collection
was one thing that was discussed um in
fact
adding density can lower those costs
because it tends to be more expensive
and studies do bear this out to have to
spread all of your utilities whether
it's sewage power uh telecoms um garbage
collection over a wider area and that's
what you're doing if you prevent people
from being able to live where they want
to live in walkable areas particularly
students but not only students then
you're forcing them to the periphery
where it then becomes necessary to have
more cars it creates more traffic and
and involves more maintenance costs for
all of the infrastru structure so um I
think in the long run and in the short
run as well actually it's more
beneficial to allow through just basic
property rights people to live where
they want to live in the manner that
best suits them where they're not
causing a nuisance to anyone else so
thank you very much again for the
opportunity to testify for the last time
I will trouble you today but the
institute for justice very strongly
supports House Bill 457 and I'm happy to
take any questions thank you for your
testimony questions from Mr
Hooper seeing none thank you very much
and the last speaker I have is Nick
Norman
welcome
back it's been a few week thank you for
being back I haven't been here in I
don't know a
week um um I skip the introduction we're
short on time I'm sure you know me well
we're here to support this bill we think
it would infringe property rights to not
be able to rent to unrelated
people uh just a couple points
that I agree so much with people are
people in today's world there's so many
different ways that people live and
Lifestyles they live and the types of
people that they are I see no reason we
see no reason to restrict housing based
on um familial status and whether people
are related or not I like the example of
you you have okay so it's okay now to
have eight people in a four
bedroom if they're each couple is
married but it's not okay if they're not
it just the whole thing just doesn't
make sense um as property owners and
housing providers sometimes we get
people coming to us that we got a two
bedroom available it's two
couples adult couples and they might not
be married but we see no reason why
would we restrict that rental maybe
they're together because they're trying
to save costs it's
expensive and that's one of the ways
they can do it and maybe they've been
great friends for a long time I like
some of the examples that that Gibbs uh
as representative Gibbs gave of people
living together in a supportive
environment there just no reason to see
these
restrictions um what else did I want to
say quickly uh it's too much government
inference don't you
think government comes in to
say you can't you can't stay here
because we don't like your your
lifestyle
your your
relationship U there's way too many
there's many types of people and
students come in all kind of variety
right there's people that are quiet and
focused and and life will be around and
and some that cause problems so yes I
think we should have the the laws that
already exist for trash and disturbance
and so forth be enforced that's that's
the
solution um I
I guess that's really all I want to say
we're in support of the bill as written
and um I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you Mr Norman
representative Kerwin thank you chair um
I know that we're talking about um
student housing in this bill but taking
your philosophy would you then apply
that to sober homes halfway houses um
other group homes and boarding houses
they're sort of I see no reason to have
restrictions based on
um familial first of all it it's got to
be
illegal it's discriminatory to say
you're going to discriminate based on
familial status based on
relationship so yeah I think we all of
the all of the possibilities should be
open we should have all possibilities
open especially now in this housing uh
issue that we have you know why why
tighten it up and make it more restrict
we need to loosen things get more
housing options
available certainly not government's
business to put their nose in people's
private
lives thank you for the question any
other questions seeing none thank you
thank you is there anyone else here to
testify on HP
457 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing
256 and I'm going to immediately open up
the public hearing on HB 465 and I want
to recognize the prime sponsor
representative Wade welcome
and I only have one pink card for this
bill if there's other ones please hand
them up so I know what we're dealing
with that's all right I know it's a
boring one so I I don't know about that
expect it but yeah we'll see all righty
um well thank you very much everyone and
thank you Mr chair um so I'm uh Alice
sued I represent do Ward 2 uh and
straford County 15 and I'm the prime
sponsor of this bill and here to
introduce it today um so the goal of
this bill is to take the existing
Housing Opportunity Zone Program and um
basically clarify a lot of existing
language um that's pretty vague that's
made it difficult to implement um and
make it more effective for
municipalities to use as a tool to
incentivize more affordable housing
development in their communities um so
overall the goal is just to improve this
program for municipalities for landlords
and for tenants
uh to make it more adaptable um for
different communities needs so uh this
program is within RSA 79e and basically
how it works is uh if you have a
property um that falls under one of the
uh requirements uh for this program so
it might be renovating a historic
property that's kind of fallen into
disrepair or maybe it's improving a
property to make it get more flood
resilience uh converting Office
Buildings to residential space and um
the particularly important one in this
case is affordable housing um so if uh
you are a developer you want to make
more affordable housing if you apply for
this program what you can do is you can
designate a certain number of those
units as affordable to somebody making
80% or less of the area median income
and if you do that and the municipality
grants your request then it will freeze
your property value at the current rate
uh and um basically the additional
developments that you make will be
frozen for a certain number of years
determined by the municipality so it's
basically a tradeoff so um a
municipality temporarily foros that
additional tax revenue from the increase
in property value as a off to develop
affordable housing and to improve uh
infrastructure so uh yeah that's that's
how the existing program works however
the language for the affordable housing
section is very very open-ended so um
all it says is that no less than
onethird of the current H or of the
housing units constructed shall be
designated for households with an income
of 80% or less of the area Medan income
so that's the whole thing um so it says
nothing about what happens when somebody
starts making more than 80% uh how
frequently do you verify income um of
those tenants and all of those sort of
um additional guidelines there's nothing
about that anywhere at all um so that's
left this program very open-ended for
municipalities and uh I've been told
personally by uh the do housing
coordinator or the former do housing
coordinator um that one of the reasons
that do didn't adopt this is just
because it's it's you can't you don't
have any guidelines on how to actually
implement this um so yeah this bill does
not change the income requirement it
does not change anything in regards to
zoning of where these can go or uh it's
it's all still controlled by the
town um but what it does is it kind of
gives these these guardrails in place
and this guidance for things like income
verification so to start off um there
was a question in regards to how
frequently do you verify a tenant's
income um do you verify it annually uh
do you because you want quick turnover
of the program if somebody starts making
enough money that they can sustain
themselves without this affordable
housing do you want quick turnover so
that unit can then go to somebody who
needs it more
um the other option is you would only
verify when they sign the lease and then
um just let them stay in that unit so
long as they're in good standing um and
the unit is still priced affordably um I
reached out to a number of different
people across the aisle and um different
municipalities to kind of get their
perspective on what they thought the
right answer was and I got a whole range
of different answers um which is exactly
why I didn't want to specify a specific
um annual verification or infrequent
verification because the thing is it
takes a lot of time for
municipalities um to track down this
information for landlords to make sure
they have it all in order and for
tenants um so smaller municipalities
might struggle to verify a lot of these
units annually over and over again so
they might say we'd love to have
affordable housing we'd love to
encourage more developers here using
this program but we just don't have the
staff to um verify that frequently and
bigger communities were saying oh we
have the staff we can do this and we
want quick turnover so we can make sure
this goes to the people who need it so
that's why in this bill that I'm
proposing there's a lower bound and
there's an upper bound so you can
basically choose to verify once during
the initial um lease signing or you can
choose choose to do annually um and
that's totally up for the municipalities
to
decide um just cuz I I didn't think a
one size approach made sense here um so
uh the other thing that this does is it
clarifies the question of what happens
if you start making
81% of a median income Uh current
statute do you get evicted immediately
um you how does that whole process work
there's nothing at all um explaining
that so what this does is it adds a bit
of a grace period to say if you um if
you uh no longer qualify under the
income portion you have one year where
you can just continue signing your lease
um and that's just to allow them to find
alternative housing and that grace
period um it doesn't say that you can't
be evicted at all it just says you
aren't ineligible to renew your lease um
because of this program because obvious
if you have a bad tenant you should
still be able to evict them when you
know under under um other statutes but
this is just saying if they're in good
standing if their landlord likes them if
they um want to continue living there
they can just keep renewing their lease
if they so
choose um the last thing is expanding
the eligibility of this to adus so the
thought process there is adus are often
smaller landlords um they might not want
the hassle of going through the
paperwork of verifying their tenants
income over and over again and it can
also be difficult to scout out for that
lower inome tenant in the first place so
the thought is that so long as that Adu
um landlord prices the unit affordably
then you don't have to like anybody can
can stay in that unit you don't need to
verify their income and that's just to O
increase the overall supply of
affordable housing because everybody
could use a bit more of that right now
um but yeah so that's the overall
summary of the changes in this law you
know we're in the midst of a housing
crisis as I'm sure you all in the
committee here know um and this just
tries to improve this existing program
give municipalities an extra tool that's
a bit more
flexible um but yeah so I urge you to
vote all to pass on HB 465 and I'm happy
to answer any questions about the
program thank you representative are
questions for representative weade um
representative Howen then represent
Goods I just have a quick one the way I
read it so the 80 the the designation of
the units uh that are designed for 80%
of Ami what we're really verifying is
that the that that that's establishing
the rental rate and so the verification
program is really to verify that your
the the rental rate has remained the
same that it still qualifies because we
as a municipality just gave you a tax
break so we want to make sure that we're
getting what we paid forre so it's not
so at least what we're looking at
although we don't have we haven't put
one together but it's in our Workforce
overlay the verification is really the
apartment rent not the the income of the
renter is that is that what you're
looking to fix I should I will say so um
to my understanding and to the do
housing coordinator understanding is
that the verification because the
existing statute says designated for
individuals making 80% or less they
interpreted that and I believe the New
Hampshire Municipal um uh organization
interpreted that to mean that you have
to verify tenant income to make sure
that they make below
80% um so 80% is used both to calculate
the rental rate the maximum rental rate
of a property under this program and
also to verify tenant income to my
understanding um um yeah so I I had not
heard that that was another so that's
part of the reason this law is super
super vague and part of the reason I
think we really need to make some of
these improvements so I'm happy to help
with an amendment if that would be I was
just going to say would you be open to
an amendment to to fixing that because I
think absolutely um and on the note of
amendments if I may real quick um there
was one thing that came up after I had
submitted this which is the idea of if
you expand this to
adus you know I don't want it to freeze
the property valuation on the entire
property I basically want to consider it
as if imagine an appraiser goes to you
and they'll
just pretend there's no Adu on the home
if you make other renovations to the
primary residents that I don't think
should be Frozen as part of this program
I think it should just be the Adu itself
um that counts towards that freeze um
but yeah so if we're going to amend it
I'd be happy to fix that too right yeah
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um
so just to be sure I understand this is
it then up to the town um if someone um
if they do periodic ver income
verification um and someone's income
changes so that they now make above the
80% is it then up to the town um to make
a policy as to whether that tenant would
have to leave or can renew the leas and
say yeah so um the idea behind the grace
period was to say um currently there's
there's nothing about what happens if
somebody starts making more than that um
and in my mind I wouldn't want somebody
to make
81% um so they're still not making much
uh money and then immediately be evicted
and they can't find alternative housing
I don't think that's fair to the
landlord the tenant or the municipality
or anybody involved if they're otherwise
in good standing um so what the grace
period does is all it says is you can
renew your lease for that one year um
and after that is when you'd be
ineligible to renew your lease under
this type of
property uh follow-up question y um what
about home ownership un
if somebody buys one of these houses um
that is intended for people uh who make
below 80% of the median income what
happens to them if um their income now
increases um are they required to sell
their
house sorry uh so this this applies to
renters if I'm understanding right so
are you saying if the land if the owner
of the property changes no it the it
doesn't seem to make a differentiation
between rental and Home Ownership units
it is not clear that it applies only to
rental units yeah so this program is
saying that the rental rate um so it's
meant for things like rental units and
apartments it's not meant for for
housing um it's saying that the rental
rate is fixed at that
80% um uh area median income uh
affordable guidelines which is done by
by that Federal Housing Authority that
needs to be
clarified okay represent Faxton so just
79e is an extensive law and covers a lot
of things with reference to uh
representative Gibb's question my
understanding is that what you are
proposing here only applies to those
situations where a town has adopted 79e
which most towns have not yeah and where
a specific ific tax exemption has been
obtained for providing renovated housing
spaces to people whose income is at or
below 80% of the median or whatever
you're correct um so but wouldn't apply
to if the Property Transfers if you do
that and then I buy it from you and
those tenants remain it has no impact on
the tax def the tax uh deferral to the
best of my understanding yes um but I
don't I haven't explored that case into
too much detail um where but your my my
my question to clarify for per
representative Gibbs purposes and my own
is that what we are talking about is
only in The Limited section of the law
that applies to tax benefits obtained by
provid by providing housing to uh
renovated housing to people at 80% or
below the poverty level exctly so this
this all all of these changes are only
applicable to 79
e-4c which is the Housing Opportunity
Zone program within the broader 79
statute um yeah so that's yeah so yes
you you right and in understanding that
all right other questions represent Wade
see none thank you thanks so much um
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'll be brief I'm Nick Taylor
the director of housing action New
Hampshire there were a couple questions
on the 79e program so figured I would
speak up um a couple points around the
uh income verific verification question
there are some municipalities that use
Hud's fair market rate when they're
looking at their affordability statutes
this is what Durham is looking at this
is what Dover does there are other
communities and state law which use the
area median income which are slightly
different they're very similar numbers
but they are different in terms of what
is being measured um the HUD fair market
rate typically sticks with the rental
unit as you were talking about where the
area meeting income sticks with the
person and so that's where there's been
some question about whether the unit
price versus the uh income that someone
is earning is the best sort of barometer
in policy the decision for which you
were going to give your tradeoff to um
so I would just say from housing actions
perspective we appreciate the intent
here we support the bill we think the
flexibility around adus especially
without verifying it's expensive it's
difficult makes tons of sense we
generally support the unit rather than
the income um qualifying piece just
because it is really tough to verify it
can disincentivize work when folks are
doing well but they earn a couple extra
dollars per hour then it forces them out
of a unit and I don't think folks want
that so extending this from even a year
to perpetuity I think would be fine
because folks move on um in different
stages of their life and the 79e
question you're exactly right that a lot
of communities do not use the Housing
Opportunity Zone element of 79e they use
the community redevelopment section of
79e which is really made for like
downtowns and so that's uh where a lot
of the apartment building that u79 come
in not the Housing Opportunity Zone
Program which is still relatively
new hopefully that answered a couple
questions right any questions seeing
none thank you is there anyone else
that's here to testify on HB
465 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing at 3:14 we're running a
little bit behind I know representative
howand had noticed a subcommittee but I
think there's a couple bills that I want
to exact we have a full committee here
so um I'm just going to briefly recess
and ask the Republicans to meet meet
me in the office real quick and we'll
chat um the four bills that I want to
get out of committee today are HB
685 okay so I will um we'll be in recess
till
3:30
e
can I ask the non-legislative members to
as
e
okay so I'm going to open up the we're
back committee on housing I'm going to
open up the executive session on HB 459
and I'm going to recognize myself for a
motion I move that R retain House Bill
459 is there a second second second by
representative
Paige um quick discussion I think
there's a lot of great merits to the
bill I think there's another bill that
is um making its way through the body
that we shall not name um but I think
I'd like to see both of those bills in
one spot where um the committee on
housing that is tasked to deal with this
can deal with this so um I'm going to
retain it and kind of see what um the
other body does with their version of
the bill um is there any other
that all right great representative um
reinford call the RO Vice chairman Cole
not here representative
Faxton yes representative Aaron yes
representative Buller yes representative
Dumont yes representative Grant yes
representative miles yes representative
Miner
yes clerk reinford yes representative
Paige yes representative boras yes
representative Reed yes represent
resentative Gibbs yes representative
Hicks yes representative Howland yes
representative hegner yes representative
Kerwin yes chairman
Alexander no motion carries 17 to zero
um so that will be retained over the
summer
um all right um I'm going to open up the
executive session on
HB 383 and I'm going to recognize
reprentative Dumont for a motion make a
motion to itl 383 is there a
second I second representative Aaron
second it any discussion on
this represent
Dumont well just from the testimony that
we heard today and in reading the bill I
think it gives a a small minority um a
majority say and I think that the way
that it's written is
unworkable represent all say
yes I agree with
that any other discussion on HP
383 all right seeing none I'm
representative ryford call the rooll
vice chairman Cole not here
representative Faxton yes representative
Aaron yes representative bullier yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles yes
representative Miner yes clerk Rin
yes representative Paige yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative hegner yes representative
Kerwin yes chairman Alexander yes the
motion carries 17 to Z to one um
representative Dumont if you could write
the majority report is there any
objection to this going on
consent all right seeing none this bill
is going to be on consent and if you can
get me the report in the next few days
or so that'd be great that's going to be
for that'll be on the um these bills
will be on the uh calendar for the March
6 session so we have a little bit of
time on that all right next bill I want
to open up the the executive session on
HB 577 I would like to make a motion all
right repres I would like to move OTP on
this phenomenal Adu bill all right
motion by representative Reed is there a
second I'll second
um I will um now move amendment
number 0449
H representative Cole would you like to
second
that yes I'll second it
okay um so this amendment real quick
this amendment deals with a lot of the
things that we spoke about during the
work session um it does
a few things it makes sure that the the
municipalities cannot restrict adus to
less than 750 ft which is already an
existing law it adds that back in it
also gives municipalities the right to
um regulate if the an owner occupies one
of the existing adus which I think is a
key um component to allowing U
municipalities discretion in in this um
but um it really goes a long way I think
in helping move the housing crisis and I
I think that five I think the amendment
will um enhance the bill and hopefully
get it over the Finish Line at least
through the house um is there any
discussion on the amendment at
all okay is a um show hands okay with
the
amendment all right all those hold on
yeah okay all those in favor of
amendment number 0449 H please raise
your hand now any opposed abstentions
all right the Amendments adopted now
we're on to the motion of otpa
which I made in representative Cole
second no Reed made the initial
motion all right discussion on this
bill don't all speak up at
once Mr
cheer read I support this bill as
amended I think it could do a lot more
but we get what we get and so
something's better than nothing wow okay
great all right representative buio I'd
just like to Echo representative Reed's
uh comments and I also wish that we
could have gone a little bit further but
direction that'll be really interesting
Bill to hear I'm excited for
it okay um seeing no other comments I'm
G to have the clerk call the role the
motion is otpa with amendment number
0449 byce chairman Cole yes
representative Thaxton yes
representative Aaron yes representative
Buller yes representative Dumont yes
representative Grant yes representative
miles yes representative Miner yes clerk
reinford yes representative Paige yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Hicks yes representa
Howland yes representative hegner yes
representative Kerwin yes chairman
Alexander
yes all right motion carries 180 any
objection to this bill going on
consent all right seeing none this is
going to go on consent um and I'll write
the majority report for
that huh oh do you need do you have a
green sheet over
there are you okay
good
all right briefly I'm
gonna you yeah you okay all right I'm
going to open up the executive session
on HB
685 and I'm going to recognize myself
for a motion of a to pass representative
Grant would you like to second that
second by representative Grant um and
now I'm going to move Amendment
0392 representative Grant would you like
to second that perfect um by
representative Grant so real quickly
this amendment again does things that I
addressed during the work session um it
first of all it keeps the main which is
the heart of the bill section one really
puts a key definition of manufactured
housing makes sure it's a permanent
chassis um it's it's connected to
existing utilities Plumbing Heating
electrical um but it's just built
somewhere else and shipped in so that's
really is the the Crux of that I think
that there's no reason why that
shouldn't be allowed as a as a house on
any property um I I think it's a key
solution to the housing crisis because
it allows for smaller houses and more
affordable houses on on existing
properties um the amendment moves out
the effective date allows municipalities
a little more time to um uh amend their
zoning ordinances um and allows for
non-discrimination against manufactured
housing representative Hicks yeah thank
you Mr chairman um I wish representative
Reed was here to hear me say this but I
think this is a great Bill to
start to change the narrative about what
type of
housing is allowed or pref I should say
preferred in certain neighborhoods in
certain towns in New Hampshire and it's
about time we did this thank you other
comments representative
Gibs am I correct in understanding that
the main substantive difference between
the amendment and the original bill is
the elimination of the reference to the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development yes thank you
we don't have a state department and I
don't like relying on the federal
government I don't think the federal
Housing Department of Housing and Urban
Development would be interested in doing
that anyway awesome okay thank you
that's our that's our HUD spokesman over
there all right um any other comments do
a show a hands for the amendment okay
all right all those in favor of
amendment Z 2025 0392 and H please raise
your hand now those opposed abstentions
am Amendment carry
1701 all right so the F the motion is
ought to pass as amended um with the
amendment being adopted that's 0392
representative Alexander makes a motion
second by um representative
Grant any more
discussion do you want me to
wait indicated all right so will clerk
call the
rooll vice chairman Cole yes
representative taxton
yes representative Aaron yes
representative Bullard yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles yes
representative Miner yes rep clerk
reinford yes representative paig yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed not here representative Gibbs yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative hegner yes
representative Kerwin yes chairman
Alexander
yes motion carries 1701 is there any
objection with this going on consent all
right seeing none going on goingon to go
on consent and I'll write the report for
that um that's all I had for um
executive session for these four bills
um we will not be meeting next week I
will be away in a sunnier warmer
place um oh yep
um I wanted to appoint a subcommittee on
HB 410 which is representative Reed's
bill um
the the chair of that subcommittee will
be representative Reed and um these five
reps will also serve on this
representative Hicks representative
Howland representative Faxton
representative bolo and representative
Aaron um representative re you have to
notice it 24 hours ahead of time I'd
confer with your members they also might
be away so um um but
I'm it's not an early bill so the bill
is not due out um until the the 20th but
really the 18th would be the last day
we're going to discuss that okay um now
we have nothing really left other than
representative Howland has a
subcommittee um so you can take as long
or as short as you'd like but I'm going
to adjourn the full housing committee
and uh give you opportunity to get
together thank you everyone what was the
vote on 383 I just need know that uh you
y
e